And that's probably the way to do
it with cotton. And right now, POW.
Pow. So what did it have? Tell
me about the tour bus. This tour.
The tour bus champ. No, no,
no, no. He's not. Let's,
let's hold up on labels
till we hear the story.
I've only one one victory
in this whole thing.
Tour buses. He came so close to the
weight loss. Do they come close?
And then I'm really only have one
year where it was like socialist.
It was like a Marxist. No one could lose.
Yeah. Even if you lost it didn't matter.
I like that. That was coming. Yeah.
There was a good this year. This year.
It's gotta be a good way. Listen,
last year almost killed myself. Yeah,
we've got to do it differently than that.
Your Ping fucking purple wasn't purple,
but it wasn't the right color. What
color was this word? I had brown though.
I was worried, but it wasn't, it was
just dehydration. Severe Dehydration.
There was days where I would drink
literally fucking gallons of water.
Yeah. You don't want ice. I try it
without personally. You're crazy. Um,
I was drinking so much, I was drinking
water and I was adding salt to it.
I was that in Himalayan salt to the
water was cause I know I was dehydrated
myself so much. I would have
puddles on the ground. You still,
that still wasn't sufficient?
Like did I set up a set off an alarm?
I remember that set off a fire
alarm in the gym from my sweat.
Uh Huh. Yeah. I even never heard of that.
Of course I still have PTSD from
last year. So Brock Tobar Dude,
like I get texts from you guys and
panic sits in my heart and I go, wait,
what does he like gets it?
She thinks I'm crazy for sure.
I moved and it just sets wives.
You're the only one who that dad.
You got Lou in the home life? Yeah. If
I come to New York or would have been,
I mean la would have been terrible to
be for an extra month, but like, uh,
I saw that fucking stupid
device when I was moving.
I opened up the drawer and I was like,
I didn't want, I was like, get it out.
Get out here. I want to Chucky.
Chucky the little dog. Yeah.
Yeah, man. I think Leanne and push,
you're going to podcast
this entire sober October.
She threw you under the bus
in the fucking radio station.
Tell us you guys didn't hear that story.
You guys should have white swaps.
Tell that story.
They were asking about drugs and how
hard I party and I was just talking shit.
And I was like, you know, I go, uh,
I go, I spoke a little bit of weed.
I'll every now and then if cocaine's
on a switch blade, I'll hit it.
But for most part, I only, I only,
I only do mushrooms once a year.
And Leanne just heard me and she was
making breakfast for the girls. She goes,
he doesn't do mushrooms and he doesn't
do cocaine. He's got high blood pressure.
I'm like, bitch, I'm trying
to move tickets and Dayton,
you under the bus tour. Fall dates
available now, but right now, dude. Yeah,
we do right now. Right now. Right now.
Right now. [inaudible] dot com is weird.
You sound like you're
coming off a coke bender,
Torin, hard food. But
saying, think about Tom,
like when you first started
going on the road with me,
you're way far further ahead
now than it was as a future.
Oh, right when he was opening for me, we
were doing, yeah, we were doing clubs.
We're doing all clubs.
Did you make,
we started do theaters when you started
to headline your own places. That's true.
Yeah. That was pretty crazy. Tid
was quick. I was thinking about it,
about that level you were at that we
all thought was like damn. Well, yeah,
I mean it's like you, you know someone
you're like, it's accessible. Yeah. Right.
So you're right. It seems
normal. You make sense. Like, Oh,
I could sell out this whole weekend too.
Yeah. And then when you do, you're like,
oh shit. Like what a fucking
comedian. I'm a real comedian.
I sell that a club and just,
just because we've got in shape,
I didn't even think about just because
it's so rocky. That's just because
I didn't think about theaters back then.
Like when we were all in the club.
I never thought we were just doing clubs.
Like I had done a couple
of theaters here and there,
but for the most part it was just about
just working. Yeah, that's what I said.
We was like, what do you want to do with
the curves? I can, I'd like to have clubs.
He was of the theater. I was like,
I couldn't do theater cause why?
Cause you said you could do whatever
you want. And I was like, all right,
dice caught me to go on the road.
He really planted a fucking seat in my
head one day in the back parking lot at
the comedy store. So why don't you do
the road? I said, I dunno. He goes, hey,
don't fucking just hang around here. And
he's like, you can make a good living.
He goes, you don't need these fucking TV
guys. And I was like, wow, he's right.
Oh I was thinking about it and I was
like, he's right. Does change my life.
I've said this a million times,
but you and bill burr in the back of the
store telling me it shows not that good.
You should just stick with,
stand up to Congress and knew that you
are way better than that. I'm like,
you're not even doing your standup
justice. Like I'd see you do stand up,
but it's like he hadn't
done it in five months.
He'd been fucking Thailand or some
shit swinging off of a tree by a roller
coaster with special people. I was
worried you were going to get killed.
Like you were doing so many different
things. There's so many different places.
I called him up once.
He was drunk on a motorcycle in Vietnam.
It's like what he did,
he learned these uncomplete
Lee unnecessary life skills
can apply to any man.
You remember everybody a unicycle and
be like, what is like I learned in Rome,
I could do whatever I want to know.
Okay.
He's a harder than when them
hoverboards what's harder? Oh, the dude,
those hover for in the, in the, uh, in
the ocean. Oh No, I don't mean that.
I mean the things that the kids wrote
were out on just the wheel in the middle.
And those are, we all in the middle. Rich
rebuilds, you know that youtube channel.
Do you know which putting why he's a,
he's a youtube host and he also,
he fixed his, he's like the
first guy to ever build a Tesla.
He bought a junk Tesla that somebody
had let get flooded with water and he's
just a really smart guy and he's
a tech guy. So he's like, okay,
what the fuck is in that thing?
Like how do I fix this? Like,
so all the wires were fucked up.
The battery was toast.
So the bought it crashed one and he took
the battery in the engine out of the
crashed one and put it in the one that
he owned and then rewind and went through
this crazy process to get a Tesla
to work that he eventually did.
And now he has his own,
it's what's
called the electric garage
in Massachusetts where
he rebuilds these Teslas.
But uh, what was my point? Oh, he had
one of those with a big ass fat tire.
When you ride on it like a skateboard.
That's hard. That looks hard.
That's hard to do. [inaudible] was
killed someone on a, on a segway.
One time I was in Rome and we were on
segways and I was just screwing around and
then I just hopped off and then
realized that when you hop off,
if you're lean afford,
it's the heaps going and this thing
started whipping around me just
and we're in like a big Piatsa and I let
just let go of, it didn't hit anyone,
but everyone around us was standing
dead still. Like oh my God,
I would have been bodied right there.
You're supposed to dive on it like a,
like a good hero. Yeah. Do you
know what our funding the made?
There's no way you're doing that. I'm
on it. No Way. You'd have to take it.
1315 people die.
Just walk out casually.
So I don't know what happened.
I don't know those Hubbard,
those hover boards that are,
cause I should jet skis where you
go like 40 feet up in the air.
Oh those are crazy. Those are
fun as fat. Cool. Look cool.
I like the guys who'd
like cut it turned over.
I'd like to know present and then it
starts to go down and they just start with
extra speed. Just shooting where
the Macola, what are they doing?
Those things are fun as fuck. Legit. Yeah.
I could do a back flip on one.
All you gotta do is like fall backwards
and then kick your feet around.
I picked up on that one quick. Hmm. Yeah.
There's a lot of useless skills
I have from travel channel.
Did you traveled so much?
Oh my God always bothered me.
You know why I bothered me?
Because I would've probably
done it too if I was you.
And I was like, God damn it.
How do you get out of that?
Cause I know that feeling like it's,
you have the best job ever.
You were on a TV show. You're like,
oh my God, I have the best job ever.
I'm gonna fuck I'm on a fucking TV
show. But yet you're still like, fuck,
I've got to get out of this.
Yeah.
It's weird cause you do get to go to
really cool places and get paid for it.
Yeah,
that was cool.
But you also mean you weren't thrilled
or can you miss stand up more?
I missed it.
I missed Hannah.
What was happening is Tom's
career was exploding at the time.
The day I fell off a waterfall.
Do you remember that was in aspen
and push called me. She's like,
I'm talking to Tom and he's
talking about these one nighters,
but I want to do the funny bones.
I was so far removed from stand up.
I didn't even, I didn't even
know you could do one nighters.
I didn't know that theaters were an
option and I think I was at a store a week
later and you were like,
you know Tom's doing like legit theaters.
And I remember just going, I missed,
what if I just missed it entirely?
He could have in some people do.
We all know guys that were really funny
back in the day and then they somehow or
another quit. It fell apart.
Dude. What if you had been like,
I'm going to lean into travel
channel? Dude it was, I was like,
you became a Christian,
like Super Christian.
Got a cross tattoo on your arm just to
let them know I'm really down with them.
I'm sure your reps told
you all those third church.
Go to church with a fucking golf shirt on.
When I got fired from travel channel,
I, my world melted down. That was
right when we were getting fat shamed.
I was fed getting fashion
named Leanne scheduled. Uh, uh
hello. Can you say we were getting
cut [inaudible] on a second.
You're saying you saying
you were getting fat shamed,
but you got to let people know like you
don't really believe in fat shaming.
You weren't really getting
fat [inaudible] at the time.
It was very one sided deal at the time.
I got fired from travel channel.
I was die definitely. It was one
sided and I felt it hard as fuck.
Your friend was fucking with you because
he was worried you were going to die to
do it though. You did on a major platform.
There wasn't like a morning radio.
He was on another level, put it on
his fucking special on Netflix. Dude,
imagine taking a coated appearance which
was massive at the time and you go up
now I'm going to use this for fun.
I'm not going to try to promote myself.
Dj Dad mouth is my favorite character
that anybody's ever to more than maybe
show.
When do you do that?
I love that you were doing that because
I hated those shows. I was like,
why would he do those shows?
TV is terrible.
You do morning TV dressed
up like a fake wrapper.
She's no cigarette created a character
called Dj dad mouth and he would just
show up places and the people did not
know what the fuck to do with them because
the lowest rung in all of show
business is morning television.
I'm so sorry if you listen to this
and you're a local morning television,
no slick ice delivered newspapers. Okay.
We all way better than morning host.
It's, it's one of the lowest rungs
in all of Showbiz. It's so weird.
Wrong where you're trapped.
It's like you're broadcasting out of
like a Christian convenience store or
something.
It's very strange because the worst part
two is that the four of us plus like
90% of the ax working those clubs do
not have a fan base watching that show.
What? I mean you, you put
it together, you're like,
this is definitely a waste of time. Like
we're wasting our time. Right? Yeah.
That's the only one that morning. I'll
be up at fucking six to do this. To do.
Good morning.
Hartford ain't good.
Only works when you, when you
get in trouble. Yeah. Like I,
I remember one time I got shirtless
and went up and the in the weather and
started saying, there's
thunderstorms. Tom Did DJ.
Have you ever seen Mark Norman's?
Mark Norman's is great when he just
goes up and she goes, how are you doing?
He goes, kind of gay. Let's get this
started. Hung over horny. Look at you
don't, but totally ruined it.
The relationship for the club.
Oh, 100% now I went in
there, Tracy Morgan,
Tracy Morgan's was my first
one was fucking legend.
That's the one where he talks
to some go get pregnant, pause.
That's my mating call.
Dying.
They are dying when he does
that big one in Chicago.
He was in Chicago for sure cause I know
you kept hollering at bulls to have to
get him in the middle of it and
squirt it. Come up. Just trashed him.
He just crashes. $2 million
Bugatti today. Today. Yup.
A Honda sideswiped him.
Whoa. Hell's kitchen.
I get here,
I already got hit by mortar truck driving
savage ran into a $2 million Italian
sports car.
I saw, I did a show with him
like a year and a half ago.
One of the odd ball shows and he came
in a all white Rolls Royce with a
professional like with a driver,
you know like a chauffeur and he came
in all white and had like a fucking
enormous gold chain with a medallion TM.
And I was like,
I chant looks crazy. He's like like
600,000 something. Some crazy shit.
Look at this. Look at this guy
sideswiped Tracy Morgan's convertible.
$2 million Bugatti. What he's
letting people know. Well
what's he the highest?
The Gut in the Honda's defense.
It's a very low car. He has a high car.
He probably looked over, saw nothing.
Fuck no, it was the car that was
like two feet off the ground.
It's such a small car. These cars are so
hard to see if you're right next to him.
What does that do is
insurance say when he calls,
I don't know if we can cover
this like fuck they probably,
that'll probably be like the final Straw.
Probably kick them off
the contract for sure.
What's that Tracy Morgan
interview that was kind of uh,
had to be an inspiration and
doing the Dj dad mouth right.
To me that was the first one I
remember like, whoa. I guess.
I mean someone could fuck
you can fuck with them in
that way. Yeah. I mean, yeah.
I mean it was funny because some people
would be really into having fun with you.
Like the Tracy Morgan people.
They laugh and they have a good time and
then some people the neat like I could
see how the club relationship could be,
cause we left one of the clubs when I
told him I was coming out as nonbinary and
the lady was like, what? This is like on
the air and I was like different genders.
And she was like, all right and she's
turning the TV and she was like, Ugh,
she's was,
and then she called in like we called the
PR person that drove us to the club or
to the vents and realize
she's in the congress. She
goes, what the fuck was that?
She was like, that was, that
guy is so weird. Don't bring
stuff like that in here.
I like, that's the whole point. We
don't want to come in here. They,
they think that what
they're doing is serious.
We're providing a wonderful morning
show for downtown Pittsburgh.
You're showing them how to make fucking,
I tried to try me
sandwiches so it's so dumb.
What a great sandwich. Hey, thanks a lot.
We've got [inaudible]
going to sing for us next.
I tried shitting on the last time I
went to Cleveland. It was the normal,
that's why another relationships
still fine. Um, but I was like,
there was a doctor,
but for me, I was like,
why does he wear his fucking doctor
outfit and do this on the way out?
He put a sweater on and left. Why
can't that be him? And it goes like,
I don't know. It's feels like you're
stepping into like Truman show stuff.
So contrived. There's nothing
real about, she went there,
there's like a 22 year old
PA or associate producer.
One time I went in and I said, yeah,
I'm already drunk from doing radio.
I can just put the mic on my
necklace. And she goes, why? I go,
I'm going to take my shirt off. She goes,
you will not be doing that. And I said,
no, you don't tell me what to do. She
was like, excuse me, I'll be right back.
And it came back and she goes,
what does in your
cup? And I said, whiskey. And
she was like, oh, he's drinking,
he's drinking ace and told on you, oh
my God. And I was just like, I was like,
we should probably leave. So he
just left his left. I was like,
I don't want to get anyone fired.
She's telling you you can't take
your shirt off. So their drink. Yeah.
Or have a drink.
I love how it's like she's telling me
like she found something out. You're like,
all right,
I was poor you in front of everybody.
I don't want to drag out of the bottle.
She'll, she's at an insurance company.
Yeah. It's hilarious. And people
don't know what job they're in.
Tried to take it more seriously.
One of those morning shows fucked
off like the way we're talking about.
It'd be like the best morning show.
So much green had a great, great,
what I remembering now,
back when he was like public access,
I was trying to promote the public
access to Tom Green show and he just took
over. He did some crazy highs in the face.
Yeah, exactly. Amazing. He's like him.
And then that other dude,
Jamie Kennedy,
they did their best shit where they were
like pranking people jackass and then
they just stopped. Yeah, man.
But Tom's blew up so crazy.
So crazy. Tom Green was on. I couldn't,
it was stuff I couldn't even
believe green did. Oprah. Wow.
Yes. Oprah was like, we're going
like this. It was such a phenomenal,
what was going on. Show was so big. He
milked that tight with his mouth. Yeah.
He puts slept mobile on his dad's calling
parents and then hitting the bushes.
He didn't just like, let me fuck this
man of people like my mommy and Daddy.
He put forget did people forget Tom
Greene? What happened too, but for now he,
he's fall cancer.
Had to take a break,
came back and tried to do like a
more serious show with a Humperdink.
What's this guy's name? But people
forgot how big it used to be. Oh,
they may have forgotten how big it was.
What he ended up writing one of the man,
what he did was he did what we're
all doing way before any of us,
but it was when bandwidth was too
expensive. He did. He had his own podcast.
Did it? You did. I did it at his house.
It was part of the inspiration for me
doing one. Yeah, and I even talked to his,
yes, I even talked to his company.
They were based in Denver.
I was in Denver doing the comedy works.
I talked to the company that was
doing it for him and I was seriously
considering doing something like that,
but the problem was that it like
the bandwidth is crazy expensive.
He had cables running from the desk all
the way through his living room into a
server room. He had a server room
in his house and it was crazy.
I don't know how much
money is involved in this.
He's like a fuck load of
money and he goes like,
I have to have all these people
running it too. That was Tom Greens.
That's me and Tom Green and he so he,
what essentially was was he decided
to try to do a talk show host.
I remember that Joe Rogan, the fucking
logs sleep under the short sleeve.
I left Joe Rogan and am I look for
awhile with the torn jeans you like,
I'm not coming here to
Hollywood and given up.
That was all based on one
switch he had in his house.
I know he just go on and flip a switch
and the show went on and one life.
So me and red band looked at it and we're
like well how much is involved in this?
Like what would we have to do to do
something like this? And then you know,
eventually it just led to that
and Kumiai Anthony Kumina was,
and that was big thing. Yeah. He had that
live from the compound in his basement.
And then the way that opie and Anthony
ran their show was an inspiration too
because it was just a hangout and it
was my favorite show to listen to. Yeah.
Cause it's just a bunch of guys
hanging out talking. I was like,
that's like that's what I want to do.
Four hours of them eating oatmeal.
I remember they just eat oatmeal
and you'd be like, Oh yeah,
I was a big fan back then on
the show that would eat oatmeal.
Oh you tune in early on an already there
and they'd just be eating breakfast and
just go on.
Jim would take a shit and be gone for
30 minutes because they didn't have any,
when they first talked to him,
fat chat nor day back in the day,
they didn't have any advertisers,
so they had to fill four hours of content.
So they literally, I mean
everything went. Yeah.
When they first started on Sirius Xm,
they had to fill four hours of content.
We had no commercials, no commercials.
That was the pitch crazy. That's serious.
Said, hey, we don't have
commercials. You're paid for.
He paid for it and then they just started
solid commercials. Like, wait a minute,
I fucking paying for this.
And you've got commercials to ask,
is Howard got to get to that paper kid?
It's where people are at the helm
of no fucker. Integrity goes down.
He gets kicked up sell no matter how.
I mean he's,
he's locked up in a contract for, for
Liz. I've son thought he was done.
So I got to come up. He wants more money
on shore. That's what Howard would do,
you know. But he makes up
ass load of money. You know,
there's no one even close second
second places. He's just huge.
Like he's a huge shareholder during
that lawsuit too. If we can get over,
let's say the number was
100 million subscribers,
I get this gigantic bonus
whether they bought serious,
serious and like that took us from 60
plus another 40 is a hundred so I get it
[inaudible] we acquired
that pay me mother fuckers.
I don't know what happened with it
but well [inaudible] right there.
He's respect you guys are done
with the beef and be with them.
I just think it's should retire.
But the point, the point is what is,
he did a good thing for this,
but he basically,
what he was saying was that the only
reason that deal took place at all was
because he was a, was it Sirius or
Xm? He was serious. Serious. Right,
right,
right.
So the only reason why serious was
kicking ass at all was because of Howard
fucking stern period and there was
nothing on Sirius [inaudible] him.
He started wired, it wouldn't have
acquired x. Also the model was like,
so you know,
suspect at the time you're there,
you're gonna get a terrestrial radio and
go to a place where people have to pay
for what they just turn on deserves it.
Here's why no one else
could have carried that.
No one else he was radio
and especially at that time,
during that transition to satellite,
no one else would have got people to
commit to having a fucking satellite dish
in your car.
Maybe you had those stupid
fucking antennas that you
said to put on your car to
get to get serious.
The wire went all the way through.
Your car is gross to sue and they would
stick up like a pig tail out of the roof
of your car that she goes. Yeah. Yeah. And
how I would cut out for like every turn,
any corner, anytime there was
a building in New York City,
any fucking tunnel tunnels dead.
The city that existed it. Yeah,
whatever money that country,
that company makes.
The only reason it's still or Howard stern
for sure. Only reason. Yeah, for sure.
This say no,
I had XM and it was until Bennington
and opie and Anthony showed up.
It was painful or listen to yacht rock.
Yeah. Oh yeah. It was cool though.
You like nineties rock, three different
channels of a hundred different channels.
It was, yeah. It was worth
a dollar a year. Great.
Best through. He's been doing on stage
lately. I hated my storytelling show too.
Recently. Did the same thing, just
talking about the good old days,
a fucking drug addiction
of yours to get down.
He describes this city that you're
like, oh my God, I want to be there.
Go what year? What first time
in the city? I went, I left.
I went there six years. Oh, first time
I've ever been in there. Yeah. Oh,
like do you see times square when
it was time square? But I was like,
what's up when we're wearing
a bra? Just a Bra. My mom,
what they did at Times Square, they turn
times square into like Disney mall is,
it's New York's version of
like 12 like Disneyland.
It's disgusting and it's a
nightmare whenever you're visiting.
And also like when you're visiting,
you're in a car,
you don't need to go to this and all of
a sudden you look up and you're like, oh,
we can fucking time. Like you're
just driving through it. I'm like,
we gotta get Outta here man. Like
the chaos, the, and it's just like,
it's too commercialized. No commercial,
no reason. It feels like you're, yeah,
everything that makes New York
amazing is like gone. God,
you're gonna just do a funny joke about
it with your coat for a meeting and then
like you're walking in and people just
looking up and he's like, why is that?
What gonna fuck yeah. Who says that? Jim
Gaffigan. Oh, that's funny. That's funny.
Yeah. Well it's like
a, it's very Vegas ask.
It's like walking down the strip.
Yes it is.
It's like are the lights and the total
control? It's fake. There's no M and. M's.
That's not where it was invented.
So why is a giant m and m store and when
you knew used to know what it was like
with like peep shows and xxx everywhere.
And it was, it was seedy and weird,
but every dangerous, it was dangerous,
like legitimately dangerous.
[inaudible] I mean the worst time what?
Seventies eighties right.
That was like the worst crime time,
late seventies into the,
to the mid to late eighties I was hanging
out in New York in the 80s when I was,
that was my pool hustling days and uh,
I was doing a lot of gigs.
I guess it wasn't the 80s it
was the nineties the early
nineties cause by 91 was
I think the first time I
ever performed in New York.
91 or maybe 90 of them really? Well, this
is like, you're just starting out though,
kind of. You are going to
Amsterdam barriers then. Yes.
What was this Chelsea Chelsea billiards.
Chelsea handler's.
There was where we would go to Amsterdam,
but Amsterdam is on the west side.
Back then it was on ams moved.
That's why it was called Amsterdam
Pemex since it was on the west side.
It was an awesome place, I call it.
That's why I became friends with Don.
My rera played pool with him in
[inaudible] 94 at Amsterdam billiards.
I didn't know he like when I,
when meet a pool player,
like a comical actually plays like
dom could play. He called me today.
I can't wait. I'm going to back off
that guy. I love him so much. But uh,
New York was a different place,
man.
I was around a lot of these like Weirdo
homeless, grifter type characters.
A lot of due to get arrested
for doing three card Monte.
Like the pool hall was the best
education of like street culture.
Like people who live on the street,
I mean home people,
people were basically homeless.
Like sometimes it's still here.
They're like my friend Johnny was
always like staying in people's,
hey stayed at my house for,
sometimes he would stay in these weird
little hostels and flop houses in New
York and places that didn't have a roof.
Like you have walls,
but there would be like no rules.
So like everybody can hear everybody.
Remember as a kid in that era,
the perception that you had of New York
is like, this is nothing but crime. Right?
Like they say, it's dangerous. You're
not allowed. Giuliani, you know,
clamped down on all that shit.
Yeah.
I remember when I moved and I,
I found a place,
I came back to get my stuff and
I told Neil Brennan, I was like,
I don't think they have bars in my back
window door and need that. It goes,
I'll do read the crime stats.
It's a different city though.
It's just not that city anymore. Yeah, it
was sitting in the war was already safe.
That was, I mean, I
don't remember any crime,
which although I did get taken and
three card Monte a number of times,
but they didn't force you use all three
card money. You know my brain, I'm like,
I fucking got this fucking put money
down. Larry is too high. So that,
and they used to have this game where
they had a a nail in a piece of board and
yet a hammer and you had three shots to
get the nail in that they had that in
Thailand. Dude, I do that
over every fucking time.
There was so much so hard.
There's so many hustlers right
back in those days in New York.
So many people trying to get
off some kind of scam. Yeah,
I guess I've been scammed by a driver
in New York. How, what? It's like,
this was not even that long ago.
I mean it was probably like seven,
eight years where no, like you get
in the cab and you're like, you know,
if you don't live there but you kind of
know like the layout, you're just like,
basically I want to go up, uh, you
know, 20 blocks this way. Right.
And the guy just goes across town and
starts going up like the opposite highway,
like one where we were, I'm like,
which, what are we doing exactly?
There's already that you can
track yourself on your phone.
Just looking at it like what are we doing?
And he's like going up to the, I go,
couldn't you have just gone up that
avenue that we were on? And he was like,
I don't know what's going
on man. I'm like, I go, well
this is fucking outrageous.
And then we pull up, I see like the meter
go and go and I'm like, this is crazy.
That was supposed to be a a 10 minute
drive and it's taken 40 minutes. He goes,
just pay me what you ever, you want
to pay me what? Yeah. And I go, okay.
Because he didn't want to get
caught. Yeah. And I go, okay, that,
so I go like the things had like $68 and
I was like, here's 20 bucks. He's like,
that's it. I gotta use my pace, but
I want to pay so I'll see you man.
Yeah, I bet it was. He was totally cool
with it. Yeah, because he scared me. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I did that Israel wants in
Jerusalem. When I got there, I took a,
I was like, take me to belay
Brock. And it was, I didn't
realize I was three blocks over.
He could, he just told me like, oh,
that's right there dude. But it took
me around the city and then let me off.
And then when I wanted to
go home afterwards, I was
like, what? You right here?
Find out. Yeah. That's how you find out
that out on my way on that cab ride,
because I started texting people
at the next place. I was like,
I was just leaving here
and I'm going to see you.
Should I be on the fucking
passport? And they were like, no.
So you didn't speak Spanish in that
moment. He was a rush from that.
I would've taken, I would've taken,
I would've gone right to Spanish,
got into a language that makes me feel
powerful. Nigerian pocketed it and uh,
in Florence and I went into Russian,
everything, every word I knew in Russia,
my yelled at the guy and he ran because
he was like, I don't know what I'm doing.
Like Russians are fucking
animals. She yelled out, America,
you fucking trader Shitty,
yelled out America and take your fucking
shirt off and said, I'm the machine.
And started running after her mother
fucker one my wife yells up by me,
he's scared.
More scared of you than [inaudible].
Ah, I should write that
down. Write that down.
You should write that whole thing down
about you talking about on the radio.
That is hilarious.
And then went downstairs then because the
audience is going to be like, so wait,
what do you do?
Then you pull out coke and you do a
bunk [inaudible] everybody and then you
start making no sense and then
the blood comes out of your nose.
It's an awesome show. Yeah.
You could do math if you want.
If you don't want to
do the coke that night,
you take your high blood pressure
medication on stage. That crowd. Yeah,
I would.
I would love to know what I'd love to met.
Start growing this cocoa plants.
The kind where you just chew the leaves.
You can grow them here. Climate
suitable. You can get there. Yeah,
you could. You could organize a
closet with some heat lamps and shit.
Do you think so? Yeah, for sure. And I
just have just to like chew a little bit.
Well,
let's find out how many people are growing
their own cocoa leaves in the United
States. I don't think I ever want to
walk you hot. Why wouldn't you have?
I would love to so much of it.
That's why those female cocaine,
Peruvian leaves, those just want
to be like one of those bears.
I would love to talk to Aubrey Marcus.
It's the crazy happened.
You chew those leaves.
It's actually not bad for you at all.
And the team coca tea is great. I've had
that. Yeah, that'll Seattle. Your nausea.
You know what can we especially
you get to like, I'm serious.
Like everyone starts drinking it. You
still have to sign me up. It's great.
Isn't it crazy that everybody just thinks
that this one thing as the processed
chemicalized fucking version
that Scarface and clocked me.
How many people have died
because of cocaine? Oh my God.
Oh Lord. How many murders?
Is there another drug on the planet that
is inspired more murders than cocaine?
Yeah, right. I would,
I would love to know murderers versus
number of Dick sucked for it. Oh,
that'd be so funny
man.
If everybody got murdered every
time they did coke, they don't.
But a lot of people get
their dicks poke like
[inaudible] might not be everybody,
but it's like 30% so the name,
cause girls can't afford coke too.
If they're young and they're partying
and they're out and in some fucking guy
comes along with a fat Tracy
Morgan like gold chain.
That's how good coke is though.
Yeah. That's how good it is. Right?
That that people are like for
sure I'll just blow this stranger.
Oh yeah I have that. I knew a guy. So
who would get coke that didn't do coke?
They would get coke
just so they have coke.
So how it around for those whore women
if girls want to co cause some girls when
they want coke [inaudible] I am calling
somebody and I'm going to get some
fucking coke and I'm gonna leave here.
Hold on, hold on. We got some coke.
So though she knows a guy
damn orgy going on. Why?
Some of it's just girls are like,
oh I know my blow job is worth stuff,
so what can I get out of it?
What am I looking for?
My brother in law told me that he went
to Woodstock too, you know, like what,
20 years ago, whatever it was. Yeah.
Had he said this guy got one of
his friends got of a long line,
this is an orthodox Jew,
kind of a long line with a bunch of food.
Like it took forever to get
through concessions and she goes,
look at my waiting in a line. I'll blow
you for that food. And you go, yeah, sure,
let's do it. Wow. Absolutely
sucked his dick for food. Food.
That's like your chips. She got
a little extra protein. Wow. Wow.
We had a,
uh,
be real from Cypress Hill and he was
showing us the footage of him on stage
crowd surfing. He was onstage
in front of, in Woodstock,
half a million people in
the fucking crowd and then,
and then goes out into the crowd,
crowd surf and they stole a sneakers.
They took his sneakers and uh, both
people both left and the right sneaker.
They came to the, one of his shows
and he signed it in the future.
Your shoe from Woodstock, we sign it.
It's like, fuck. Yeah. And he signed.
That's crazy.
That's wow.
It's the video of him on stage in front
of half a million people. It is insane.
I love how they,
the Sandra's house have not
wavered at all from their day one.
Not like we smoke this shit all day too.
Like if you open their Instagram right
now it's just like check it out. Yeah.
Fucking 30 years deep into this shit.
Like they don't fuck around at all.
Cypress hills,
Instagram,
like half of it is we'd videos with like
Cypress Hill music in the background.
It's just videos of people doing wax and
Dabs and bong hits with Cypress Hill in
the back of the first album is so good.
So good.
They get high the way we get high. But
you and I know they do. I went with them.
They get way higher than that but I'm
saying do they like, are they out of it?
No Man, look, he's fine.
He's got that show called the smoke box.
You can see the car get a car by the way.
Can I just say,
I thought you would all Chinese Guy
Barbecue. That wasn't even there.
Are you serious? In another
dimension? Yeah. To be,
to just have a pass us a picture of you
and it looked like you were, I was like,
oh, he smoked so much before we
ever got in the car. I was like,
I can't believe we're going to keep
going. And he's like totally normal. Oh,
it's normal as could be. That's
guys, professional stoner sen dog.
They're just fine. Yup. That's not
me. That's me with booze though. Yeah,
I could definitely, I could definitely
probably like I was, I was trying
to think of like the celebrity I could
go beard a beer for and then really hurt
them. Most of them. Most Post Malone Post
Malone and then you can take them down.
Dude,
who do you think he's a young guy with
scribbles on his face. He's an awesome,
he's a great fucking
musician. Musicians. Awesome.
His tattoos requesting a,
they're odd.
What is a who taught choices
really fucking take it down. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Like drink heavily.
And I think if you, and now this is,
I've thought about this a lot,
if I go for their cocktail and I got to
match them cocktail the cocktail, um,
I can keep pace with Stan hope. Uh,
that's a big one. Key of stand up. Jesus.
Stand up. Doesn't drink as
much as everyone thinks he
just drinks every day. Yeah.
Like, like, yeah. Like he's not like
a lot of it's left to right. Yeah.
Thanks a lot of light beer.
Oddly enough.
A lot healthier than I think people
assume Ron white would be a tough one.
Oh yeah. Wrong white, white goes. He
gets fucked up every night of the week.
That's possible. Like every night
of the week. Every, not every,
not every night. It's all know
how to do. Damn. But he's,
it looks like $1 million and
he did 10 years ago. Happy man.
I'll tell you that. That's a happy dude.
He looks great. Yeah. He's 38 years old.
So boys were brought here for a reason,
not just to talk shit.
Jesus. We're trying to figure out,
um, how to do sober October this year.
What are we going to do of October?
I will already have the answer and I
think it's early for me to say it now,
so I'll wait until the end. Oh, you sound
sounded. You have your, your thought.
I know exactly what we're
doing. Okay, so this,
just tell her this happening though.
Gloats over.
Tom's got an aggressive schedule. I
think we should go. No coffee. Okay.
Really stepping up.
Stop Sobriety.
But if I were with us on a coffee because
I think we should make it harder. Like,
no, no booze, no alcohol season.
No coffee is on thick. Ooh,
no water. It's Tom Sober sober. You're on
a mild stimulant. I think it's cheating.
I think we should go. No coffee. I
like no coffee. I like no coughing,
no coffee on wait, wait, wait.
Should we realize you can only drink water
the whole month? She no other drinks.
I'm fucking in no other drink.
Sparkling water.
Bob Brown. Come on. Carbonated
water. It's just water.
No, that works. I like where you, Oh,
I'm ramping up. I'm ready to go to war.
Wait only water and carbonated water.
Yep. I'll do that. I'll do that.
I'll do that. Oh, so no coffee. So what
do you wouldn't have milk in their coffee.
Wow. Yeah. We should go
carnivore diet all month.
Nothing but Ribeye steaks.
All right. Relax. Why not?
Because you're going to get
that fucking [inaudible].
I'm willing to negotiate and I'm willing
to negotiate with what I think our
challenge should be for what
you think our should be. Well,
what do you think the challenge would be?
I know I have an idea of a challenge
to be [inaudible] is about health,
right? Yes. Yeah. Health. It's
not, what do you want it to be?
I think it should be, if mental health
is a, is a legit part of health,
you should give up your fucking dopamine
fucking addictions and get rid of cell
phones. Yeah. Get rid of your cell
phones in your social media for a month.
I get your, uh, I get why you
wouldn't do it. Cause your career.
You can email your fucking ladies
to fucking post shit for you ladies.
Enjoy social media. Yeah,
I know. Oh, it's boots
enjoying it. I think you have a good
point with this. I do. I really do.
I think about you sometimes when I,
when I feel like I've been on like a
flight or in a hotel room and I'm like,
I think I've been looking at my phone for
like three hours thinking about having
gone out. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Just being
like, just think it takes the, the um,
the connective tissue away from this,
this challenge to the people that
enjoy watching this challenge.
I think a lot of people enjoy that will
be, that will be a problem. I mean,
I'm going to be able to join in
with those. The Rock. Let's do it.
And then November 1st everyone's like,
oh yeah, you guys did sober October.
I forgot about that. I could get
each of you and I'll could tell. No,
I understand.
I'm not like Joe who says do what I do
and then I'll just fucking have an easy
time of it. I will go with no cell phones.
I will do beyond what I already do.
Let's, let's, let's, you didn't do
what you guys did though, eating,
doing yoga down to join us.
That was [inaudible] I'm saying it wasn't
a challenge in that like there was no
contest. If it was, I had to do
a yoga the most like I do it.
Right, right, right, right,
right. That's it. That's it.
Maybe it's the most 90 minute yoga class
showing that
most elks tend to go to war or kills
the most Alex and can reverse to Garcia
here. His mental health.
It's a good point. We, uh,
we definitely look at these
fucking things. You can also get a,
like a legit real camera
if you wanted film stuff,
give it to your fucking assistance that
you could have the post to figure this
out and post whatever you need to
be. How about this? How about this?
We run the most miles in a month.
Track it track.
Let me just go for my baseline right now.
How many miles a month to run right now?
It's up there, man. Okay. What about you?
Bart
has to be real running.
I wanted it on the glass. I don't want
that bullshit on a fucking treadmill.
Running shoes with a Bluetooth capability
in them will wear the wrong shoes.
So we're going to listen.
We're gonna run from miles,
but it's not fair because already
doing, I'm only running hills, man. Oh,
how many of them when you go for a
run now, it's no more than an hour,
hour and 15 minutes. Same. Same
number. That same marathon right
there? No, no. Up Hills. Up Hills.
He's probably running six miles.
I'm running some steep shit.
It's more like, it's,
it's more a sprinting.
It's like there's a lot of plyometrics.
It's more like that. Like you're, you're,
you're not just flat running at
a steady pace. So do you sprint,
run out chasing my dog too. We're having,
I'm trying to make it hard. I mean,
I pretend things to chase in me. I played
a little bit and games in my head. Yeah,
that's nice. That pretend to have to get
to the top where everyone and no dyes.
Yeah,
you're good at this shit.
Give me a hint. Whatever you got in
your brain, give it to me a little bit.
When I work
you don't want it. Um, cause it ramps up,
ramps up that's ready to go and
listen. Crazy. We were going guys,
we were working at like six, seven
hours a day. It was terrible man.
But the whole time I was like,
man, I do zero working out.
So this is called [inaudible].
Great. All right. When you were here,
when we were like three weeks
into the month and you were here,
we did a podcast together
and use my fucking rower.
You did an hour on the rower and you
were ripped. Do you have a six pack?
I was like, look at this mother fucker.
I know. It was pretty impressive.
An hour on the rower is real work.
That's real work.
You are not going to not get second
or was not gonna not go last.
That's why would you not want it?
Here's what I, here's what I,
here's what I'm hearing already.
Wants to do a challenge that he already
excels at. I get it. No, no, no.
But you're already off and you're
complaining about Joe. Is that he is,
is that he keeps logging in things
that he is good at. So yeah,
I will take care of this
since you gentlemen, are you
ready? Oh Sir. This year,
sober October.
Physical challenge like you're presenting
it like presidential candidate.
It's like an apple when it's going
to be good hip hop dance hip hop in.
Joe, hear me out. Just hear me out. Hear
me out and spin. Let me soft sell you.
Let me stop.
[inaudible] okay.
We each get a choreographer and we
work dance classes as much as we can.
Dance classes are pretty aggressive.
We leave it to the audience to vote here.
Listen, hear me out when I'm sorry. When
I liked that idea Joe. We can do that now.
Hear me out. Starting with each my 1st of
October. That's what you do on a pitch.
You make them think it was their
idea. Yeah, we got this right.
I want you to look over at that belt.
You'd never getting that but hold on.
Hold on one second. Hear me guys. Hear
me out. Everyone listen to me. Yeah,
you should watch out for this
shit.
Is putting the fuck his belt on.
Oh, okay. All right. I haven't even
touched this thing since October.
Same as me with any
sort of rough belt man.
We each got to go to dance
classes to get our skill set up.
We each worked with a choreographer to
create our own dance to the exact same
song. Let me know when you're done at the
end. At the end, at the end. By the way,
I'm selling this to the
room, like threading that
through your genes get popped,
like snaps in the bag at
the snaps at the end of the,
I have a hard time putting belts on too.
If at the of the month
come November 1st, we each submit our
one minute hip hop dance choreography,
choreography video and the fans vote
on who the winner of sober October is.
Gentlemen, I would like to hear your
bottles starting with Thomson [inaudible].
I gotta tell you are watching this,
the rebuttals punc holes in it.
You put, you put, you sort of mentioned
that. Here's what I'll tell you.
What I like about it is easy to say what
I don't like about anything that comes
out of your mouth.
So what I don't like about it or what I
do like about it is that no one's great
at it. I do like that it
is a workout because those,
those dancers are unbelievable.
I'm one dancer right now.
Me obviously first Joe seconds,
not even close.
What are you talking about?
It's definitely me. What?
I'm way better dancer than you
guys out of your fucking mind.
Just cause you see Spanish doesn't mean
you're a better. Do you like to dance? No,
but I know I'm better dancer
than you guys. First of all,
I want to fucking
listen.
I could do a lot of crazy shit with my
body. You guys can't do and that's true,
but I'm saying rhythm to them.
You have rhythm.
Yes. All right. Wait, hold on.
You have rhythm. I know I do.
I'm fucking phenomenal at dancing.
Well here's okay,
but know what I'm saying is that nobody
Xcels I mean obviously I'm better than
you, but nobody excels. So I like the idea
of working at something that, you know,
no one's great at and all this meat
dancing. Oh, that's right. Yeah. So movie.
I was in the movie zoo keeper. Yeah. I, I,
I took dance classes. Oh, all right. Uh,
dance my ass off bitch.
I love problem movies.
Make it seem normal that that
guy could get back. Girl. I know.
Ever so often. You, oh wait, hold
on, hold on. Let's see Joe. Okay.
Like legitimately,
I mean I'm not good anything.
So this is hip hop dance we're
talking about. Look at his face. Yeah,
it's intense dance.
Come on son
S. Oh yeah, you did pretty
good there. Actually.
I took fucking dance lessons.
I didn't do it for weeks.
So you're dancing with Nikki Glaser?
Leslie Bibb. Oh, she's from uh,
Talladega nights. Yeah, she's great.
She's great. Very, very funny person too.
I think that sounds like a done deal.
And else have any, here's the last thing,
the last thing. That is great. Okay.
So everybody gets to work at it.
Nobody excels too much at it.
I think it's funny that we're comics and
we get to look silly doing something.
Yeah, I could not look great
at it and I'm on board with,
I think it's fun that people that watch
that or get really into it would have a
say in it. I'm the only one of the
three of us. There's not obese,
so it would look the least
silly for me to doing it.
You're calling Joe fat medically
obese, so I think that's, sorry,
I'm about to be on my son.
Yeah, it's all about the BMI.
BMI is off the chart as you're
saying that you are into it or not.
I would look at least silly
just in terms of that,
but you guys, I get why you look
silly. Just moving at all. Mm,
well you also need these silly,
yeah, I'm not a fucking fat,
but you don't make yourself always,
you're always breaking.
Break yourself before you break ankles
and elbows and shit owns breaking through
and breaking stuff. That's super fucking
vulnerable. I am. It's a good point.
What about injury? What's intriguing
not do at this point? No, no, no.
Dance classes are intense.
Do you really think you the
current best answer easily.
I think bars most I the most
out of all of us. I agree.
And so the dance classes are taught,
we get each get ourselves choreographers
and we create our own dance to the
exact song hypes up. Wait for
me to talk about this. Okay,
but the amount of Molly I would have
to do to, to enjoy that dancing,
but you can't be sober.
Can't be solid,
but you can't November 1st
is that when we posted it,
you can be ideas that dance
partner dancing, sober,
sober fencing. Strober here's, here's
problems with it. I'll never want,
it's subjective. You can't have
something subjective you can't have.
So the other thing to him dance better.
We to think over dance better.
You can't have a bunch of morons vote for
it. Okay, let me, let me break this down.
Finish up. I'm going to
write to what if, what if?
What if the dance pros got together?
That's what I was sec.
Perfect professionals
judge. Well yeah, they're,
they're out there and they like
Burt better. They like me better.
You don't want that. No. Judges choose it.
The most corrupt people that all sports
[inaudible] they literally go to jail,
but so we have to upgrade O'Brian
and Olympic judges. No, no.
Nothing subjective.
We gotta grind dances.
We got up. We got to make it uncomfortable
there. Make it super uncomfortable.
Do you want to make her comfortable,
comfortable hands classes? It's all right.
Teen dance, dance classes.
Hip Hop does something.
It's something about the fitness
challenges that are more exciting to me.
Cause this daily fitness all the
time and wonder what that is.
I'll do something that you guys don't do
a fitness challenge you guys don't do.
Yup or that I don't do.
Rather than write that. Okay,
that's you're trying to say that
I don't ever do, I'll ride bikes.
I'm gonna give a fuck.
Bikes,
bikes everywhere, right by
store. Accessible ride bikes.
But Tom's in Europe ride a bike pitch as
you go to your ride bikes over there in
Europe in October for a
lot of those countries.
Are the scheduled in Australia sort
of cancel yet. It's coming up. Oh,
come on. I'll take a sip. When do
you cancel it? I can't sell clothes.
Why are you gonna cancel it?
I've canceled before. Just once.
I think it was Dwight. Couple of
times you get sick. Australia.
The only time he's been to Australia
was opening for you with UFC ticket.
When also at another time I went, I did
the Melbourne festival. Yeah. Yeah. Hey,
I'm in Oakland. June 5th takes this
Sydney June 20th give out dates.
Oh, that's all right. I'll be in Columbus.
I know there's a bunch people that
are doing, we will [inaudible].
We want to be able to vote well then
not gonna water. No one's stealing this.
You're going to have to earn this
motherfucker. So you're saying this,
you're thinking this hip hop has,
this is mine. This is mine. I like it.
I like it. I'm going to keep it. I'm
going to keep this. This is mine.
The flaw he saying is that there's not
like a clear right that it's, yeah,
you can't leave it in the hands of
the judges. Get the fuck Outta here.
That's rule number one for fighting.
Never leave it in the hands of the judges.
Rule number one. It's probably like
rule number of guys down there first.
It's like watch out further like or
sometimes perhaps up to number one,
smile as celebrities in the audience.
Do your cardio.
Donate like shit. I would
love to see those guys they
wanted to do too. It's like,
can we leave this to the judge was like,
dude,
just fucking worry about
[inaudible] to the judges.
I need to know.
Oh my God.
That's funny.
That was really behind your dance idea.
Dancing would be tough.
I do have a gym for you.
Home was a place right
near by me. Joe. Joe,
I think you're overestimating your dance
skills. Hip Hop, dance, not dance skills.
I'll learn them. Would it be an
amount of time in my body better?
I learned them. You know how to
move your body. You better for sure.
You don't lose moved. Moved my body
better than you can move yours.
Do you think we get Shakira
to just even say that?
Do you know crazy?
It is for you to say that my physical
dexterity in your physical death.
[inaudible]
talking about Joe,
Joe Kelly Ripa wobble. If I got through
that challenge and you didn't prepare,
you came in last like you
did with this last one.
We read [inaudible] put a sock in a
fucking with a lock in it like a bike lock
and beat your ass punishment for this.
I'm cool with punishment.
That's a good idea. Barrio punished,
right? Like, like full metal jacket.
Borrow Code Right. You out with
a bar. Soap in a sock dance.
I think that even Matthew Modine got in on
this number. Yeah, he did. That's right.
Yeah. Until he felt bad about being, I
don't know if this is the real thing.
So you don't know if,
what's the real thing?
I think you need to keep
pushing her hip hop dance works.
Stick with your challenge.
If you like.
I could see us going through all these
fucking things and bird the as like, Whoa,
you guys beat me. I can't believe
it. Like you motherfucker.
You're talking shit the whole month.
Yeah.
Talking Shit the whole month and you
came in last. That's my game plan.
That's a good point of sandbags.
Next challenge. No sandbags.
Fucking October. You be fell
apart. Dude, I fell apart. Okay.
When are you started posting these giant?
He, he was on the bike for four hours.
Like what? Oh Fuck my
head up. Todd got bad.
Jeff fucking, we started, we started
off with like 200 points was a good day.
It was like, it was like that scene
in big when, uh, when I'm uh, love it.
So tell us, uh, what's his name? Like,
Hey, slow down. Slow down somewhere.
You can make us all look bad. You
know, we're all doing as an easy, easy,
easy, easy, crazy. Anybody
was going to take it.
We don't know how much or how much we
hated each other to the really drive us to
not be, well, I don't know how you
looked at it, but I love you guys.
I just thought it was a fun competition.
She's flipped the fuck aring stand by it.
I was the most amount of
points you ever put in a day.
My biggest point day was you
ran 13 miles one day. Yeah. Oh,
broken up. No, no, just, I
mean like just going and going.
I did it in the hills and you know,
just kept up, ran like to another city,
came back since he ran 13 fucking miles.
That was after he was sick for a week.
That's what I almost dropped
out. I was like, oh he's
done. Cool. Yeah, we got home,
we took the photo thing,
Gash, sandbag dust.
Why did you take the
foot off the gas pedal?
We should've waited till he was for
sure. Tom was like, I'm sick. I'm out.
I was like Thompson last.
I don't have to worry.
I'm not in the last oh is that what you
were worried about? Cause I was like,
I was competing with Tom. Tom and I were
neck in neck. Ari was a fucking cunt.
And we just post the numbers
in the middle of the night.
You'd go to sleep like two thirds in.
Oh he didn't start like that.
I posted the Middle Lane Cause I,
my gym,
blink fitness would allow me
to work out 24 hours a day.
So I'd cut off for,
it was fucking ridiculous.
Fucking go work out three items that
was fucked my head up, man. I'd wake up,
you wake up and you're like, you play
Masti play nasty. Forgive me late spots.
It's not my fault. It's
all St. It's tricky, right?
[inaudible] gameplay.
But here's what I realized.
You guys woke up like, Oh, what? Yeah,
I'm not in first. We'll give this.
I like this. Here's what
I've, okay, keep this.
I think you guys should do
a dance off anyway. Well,
he does have that incredible
physical dexterity.
They would need a way
for judges to decide,
but that's not about working out
though, right? Hip Hop dancing,
no hip hop dancing.
If you're going to get good,
you're going to be dancing
every single day. Dot.
That's how you, I don't like doing it,
but that was a good restaurant. Why is,
somebody showed me a tweet I made
recently a year ago. I'm like,
how did we get from Burt
can run a marathon to all
gonna go straight edge for a
month.
What the fuck happens.
Exactly what we got from
[inaudible] couldn't run a marathon.
He couldn't do it faster
than your dad did.
Suddenly we're all straight US
holocaust survivor and then he was,
but he was also like,
I can run a marathon tomorrow
easily. Technically kind of did.
Yeah, you did. I tactically dead.
I did blow the doors off. You guys.
You were really, really amazed.
But I think the real test was that Tom
was going to try to rollerskate and
marathon fashion,
but he didn't take into account going
uphill or the fact that he has never
rollerskated. Yeah, but that's easy to
learn. Kids are flat four wheel like.
It's like fuck,
look out for us.
What do you think would have happened
on the roller skating part of it after
running that marathon? Yeah.
Uh, you are crushed. You,
you probably would have beat
me. Yeah, it was a flat.
You don't have la [inaudible]. No, hold
on. La Marathon was uphill downtown,
but once you got past the store,
you would have been hauling
fucking ass down Luciana guy.
I would never call him
from seller to them.
Nobody is checking them off and he got
hurt a couple of rollers getting people
and they like, no. They said
like, your feet are going to,
you're going to be in rough
fucking blow out as cash.
[inaudible]
lightly.
We're,
we're warriors.
I get it from people that have been
doing it for years and also like,
what does that, the Roller Derby
people, they were like, yeah,
you gotta be careful with it.
Just think about skiing for five hours.
If you had a school of greatness,
that would be [inaudible] ski for five
hours straight without going up lift
hills, going into the lifts, up the hills.
If you just skied all we only
on your feet for five hours,
I bet you it'd be hurting. Oh yeah.
Bird. Anyway, it's, muscles are all sore.
My feet are always hurting after
a day of skiing like Jesus.
Cause you're always like, yeah,
yeah, no. It would've been,
I would've been fucked up for sure. You
got fucked up. Did you see me crash Bert?
Yeah. Yeah, I did. I did. And then I
pulled up and you were like, oh, it was,
I don't think it's broken
shark rocket is it? Put It,
put a pin in it for Comcast.
I saw you with the big dam down to this
now so up you got pen in there like a
metal piece broke off. Got some sort of
pen. You know what's good about that?
It give one more reason to
fuck with the people at Tsa.
You're going to go fucking might have
a sacrament there that they're like,
how come something's
going off to everything?
You're talking like the sector meetings,
like anything in your pocket.
I'm like the sec to me they're like,
what about belts? Vasectomy and the like,
what? What? What do you
think it's, I'm like,
I had my dick cut and you're fucking
stupid thing that you're the head of this
company decided we need to buy. It points
out that I got up a sec to me. Really.
How does it know you out of a sector?
Because it's a little inconsistent.
It's like a hard thing in there. Peanut
you want to feel it? No, it's your choice.
Interesting.
So it's calcified.
You've got like a little
rock that rock new Dick Hole,
fucking terrorist threat dance.
So I want to ask you one thing
about your challenge. You say, no,
we're not doing already. No, no, no.
I just wanted to ask her something,
but like there's not enough of, it has
to be a second part to that, right.
For the month. What do you mean?
Like, yes, there's nothing physical.
Really a good point. You know
what I mean? Like is there,
it would just be that would,
we would need a second part because right.
That is just a mental problem. Yeah.
Well, would the guys, I'm telling you,
you're not going to do it. I
know how addicted you are. Ours,
you're never going to agree to this
dancing videos. It would make your lives.
You'd be happier and you
wouldn't know why. Hm. No,
I've been off Twitter pretty much and
it's, I'm an exponentially hopper.
Twitter just makes me sad and angry.
Reading people fighting is not fun. Can I,
uh, can I show you something? Sure. Yeah.
I'm lucky for one for me.
I won't do anything,
but just unlock it and hand it to me.
I swear I won't do anything bad to you.
I have a quote about her. Okay. Ryan,
who's on the storm didn't fucking
terrified with what I just gave you.
You know what I'm going to do? No, I was
gonna look up the time of usage. Yeah.
Screenshot. Oh, it's gotta
be up there. Okay, so just to
tour dates, bro. Yeah. Okay.
So today of your life, you have
a family. You have two kids.
I started morning radio at five in the
morning until 11 hold that thought.
So while you're on morning
radio, you're not using it? No.
I was using an entirely to look up
who I was talking to, where I was at.
And while you're on there,
you're not doing it. Yeah. Okay.
What time is it right now? It's four 26
yeah, three hours and nine minutes. Oh,
I'm sorry. 300 minutes
above average today. Yeah.
Today was press doing
press for the body shots.
World Tours last seven days
starts in September, ends June,
November 23rd I'll be in Oakland.
They actually surprised me 30
minutes a day. Yeah, I don't, dude.
I fuck with Instagram a lot.
Is that on here? Yeah, it's,
we have an hour and 18 minutes. Yeah. I
fuck with Instagram a lot and that's it.
What do you do? I did I, that's
it. I don't, don't touch Twitter.
I kind of stay away from everything
I see yours? No. How bad is it?
It's a, today's not that bad. Look up
screen time for the week. All right.
Are there totally Da's?
I'm totally off my phone.
You don't touch you at all
the court stuff and post it,
but I don't read comments and
stuff that can fuck your head up.
Twitter can be aggressive sometimes.
Find out great. Used to be, oh dude,
remember that? Fun Jokes.
Yeah, I can't. I can do.
My whole thing's about, I only use stuff
to promote toward. That's it really.
SORTA.
It's like,
like October 15th hour of social
networking. It's his. Yeah,
but in seven days. Seven days.
Seven Day. Okay. Hold on. Hey,
let's get more cocktails. I'm down.
I'm pretty fun. Where's your kid? Hey,
how are we going to fucking switch him
over to fucking hip hop dance slowly.
Slowly. It starts with me. I have
a better dexterity. Lots. A lot.
How much are you at right now?
[inaudible] wait, wait, wait.
Let me preemptively say, oh sure. I was
on a bus for the last seven days. Sure.
So just a good, definitely
I'm saying at home, not home.
We're checking them or amount of
usage on the online, on our phones,
down a bus. This is, by the way,
this time could be spent reading
a book or doing something,
but go ahead and even today,
30 minutes I think is pretty low.
Six hours and 34 minutes
a day. Lastly, on a bus.
On a bus. But now, but that is
on, but no, I get your board,
but there's a far better
way to spend your time.
Here's the, but you have to bit to
kind of look at it like this too.
I'm sitting on this bus with a fucking
thousand movies you can choose from and I
do this all the
time where I roll through like I'm going
to watch a movie which is like a normal
thing to kill an hour and a half,
two hours and I'm like,
none of these interests me. I'm going
to spend that time doing this. Right.
Looking at emails, looking at social
media, looking at youtube videos.
It's if I'm saying that you can
knock off easily two hours. Yeah,
and there'd be two hours
spent just mindlessly staring
at something else or that
you wouldn't be
have a record of free
writing or that's true.
Or like you're saying that none of that
occurred or learning hip hop dance. No,
I'm saying that I will say this,
when you're bored and you're looking
out a window on a tour bus eventually,
not the first time minutes button that
maybe puts in 10 minute, 30 minute,
40 your mind's like, fuck, we're so bored.
And then you start writing big ideas.
That's true.
True.
And you're just not even thinking about
those times because you're on there.
That's true.
It's 100% true.
Wait,
so what's yours like eight minutes?
Uh, I would have to get my iPad out.
No, yours is. Yeah, take it out and see.
Ariz is surprisingly high because he uses,
is that when he's not at lights your
seven day though? I have no idea.
Seven Day was 30 minutes.
Yeah,
today was three hours and a half
to seven day was 30 minutes a day.
Average 30 minutes a day. Wait, how's
that possible second founder. Yes.
Hold a second. Phone. Use the
search part. Split screen test.
They're going to make sense
mathematically. Good. John and Tommy,
you're absolutely right. That three
hours, 35 minutes today would be,
you would have to only abuse that
out there. It's a brand new box.
Would use that 30 minutes. I was like, I'm
a fuck. Is that possible? I'll show you.
Where is it? Oh yeah. Oh, two
hours and six minutes. That's,
that's too much. What's too much advisor's
office today? I want to find it. This,
what is it?
Uh,
fuck no man.
What'd you do?
What'd you get the fucking here.
I love the one guy that
doesn't have behind high
phones walking you through your
iPhone. That's true. Oh,
five hours and 30 minutes
for 51 minutes a day. Wow.
That's a lot for hours and
51 minutes of your day.
Five of your 16 hour waking day.
And Joe's defense not to, but like,
he's got a new people all the time
and I'm sure there's times he's like,
tell me about that guy. Dot Dot,
dot. Okay. Definitely a lot of that.
I keep hearing that in my defense, my
defense, but I'm never in an authentic,
where am I? That's too much.
It's too much. It is too much.
You do do some work on your phone,
but more than that, you fuck off.
I have every nope transcribed in my phone.
All my notes from my writing,
my laptop, it's all on my phone.
Um, all my sets are on my show.
It shows your productivity on their
decision. What you using a timeline. Yeah.
It won't be,
you want it to sound like it's going
to be four hours in 35 minutes of
productivity at 20 minutes
of fucking off. No, no.
A lot of it is also watching stuff.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
safari and let's take it. Let's play a
game. Or I can go, hey, tell me about.dot,
dot. What you'd googled? Fun fucking
game. I am. I got my computer here.
Give me your phone. I got my computer.
Give me your phones. Give me your phone.
No one can go back while,
um, I have my computer here. It's
a lot of time when you look at it,
when you see a lot of hours,
a lot of waking time spent looking at a
screen instead of your surroundings. Wow.
What is the last things I googled
the driving part of that. You can't,
you're not using it. You're
fucking me and it's you.
And then it's just some porn.
How much does that go?
I only like anal scenes. You beating
off every day? No, I just started again.
Interesting. Take some time
off. Yeah, I took some time off.
I was having a hard time with it. And now
I'm now his phone. This is always fun.
I gotta call you back if he's
got a laptop that has a CD drive.
Oh it does it.
That's the right year to buy honestly.
Cause a good keyboard. Yeah. All the ones,
the ones that got an hour fucking
horrible. The problem is with that,
you can't do the same things on Instagram.
We can't post stuff from
your fucking computer. No, I
have to send it to my lady.
You can't post it for a mom. An iPad. Yes.
You probably could lock myself out
of my out of my account and I'm like,
I don't know the password.
Hilarious. SMART, smart.
It's a monopoly. Does not make for a great
sober October challenge in my opinion.
Just to watch people do nothing is not
because he's saying that it would still
get posted. Everything will
still get posted. No, no body
camera lady legit like digital
camera of this challenge.
Is that some you enjoy like following
along with it terms of what we're doing.
It's not our normal thing.
Rogan clearly is the,
it's the working out so he doesn't
have to change his life that much.
All you do is promote the
worst for you to not have.
Where you're already doing
is promoting nonstop. Oh,
he has his hip hop dancing.
Did you knock something over again?
So then what's Tom Bad
at? What pig? A father.
So we've got the,
what if we switched kids?
How do you handle this? What? What
do you do? How do you handle this?
How do we do this?
I didn't say what I hear you,
but what are those pronouns you mean?
I mean I'm saying like
I like the idea of a,
some sort of social media challenge,
like staying off social media.
It's kind of stuff that I did something.
That's the thing we were missing.
The second poll. 100% you're,
you're dead on dead on with that.
The Birkin go fuck himself with
this hip hop dance and shit. So Joe,
I do have a hip hop dance place right
near my apartment that I could go to all
the time.
I told you I'm in mandate.
You're in a Maori or do you think social
hip hop dance would be a good one?
I think it, I think, let's put a pin in
that. I think for Real, put a pin in it.
That would be at some level of acceptable.
We'd have to get judges who
dove is active. No judges.
Judges can go fuck themselves.
We want real hard numbers.
Let's put in parameters.
You can't have a bad decision that causes
a ride amongst our fans to feel like
someone unfairly got the belt.
Even if we don't do this.
There was something so real
about how good you are.
You said you're a better mover than him.
That I would love to see.
I feel like part of the month you
have to do something with that.
You know what I mean? I think the, the
audience would love it. It makes sense.
Oh, it's gotta be, here's the deal.
Let's just put parameters on worst rubber
tube or it's going to be taking place.
Thomas touring through Europe in
our hall for part of it yet. Yeah.
How many days? 10 days. That will
cripple you. You're going to get sick.
[inaudible] fitness. I'm Cardi landed
down. Forget about any fitness challenge,
son.
10 days in Europe,
all that traveling or with
those weird European diseases,
that's how they wiped out most of the
American people. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Easy to find there. His foot's
gonna have wiped out Europe. People.
Graham Hancock says that
at one point in time,
the Amazon jungle had 20 million
people and thriving civilizations,
beautiful cities, and that the
Europeans, they're dirty diseases. Yeah.
Came over and wiped everybody out.
Let's heal the thousands.
That's actually your parents.
Yeah.
Your Dad was one of those in
run away from a virus. True.
Getting rid of his dirty bugs.
Your mom was down washing or
laundry next to a caiman alligator.
He came up his sleeves that are pussy.
Hey,
tell me this. Uh, the creek and the cave,
the Legion of skanks are not
doing what the fuck they're doing.
Not doing their show at the creek
and the cave anymore. First of all,
you guys coming to me on this is worse
than Ainslie being coming to you about
the comedy store. Milo, I think
it's directly related. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. But that's why
that's what happened. No,
they were trying to do it at the creek
and the cave and the lady freaked out.
Right. She buckled under pressure.
That's not why they're moving.
They're already going to move it.
They're already gonna move it.
There's new standards opening up though.
I'll use this as an excuse maybe,
or people will say that's the reason they
were already going to move it from the
beginning. For somebody who doesn't
know what you're talking about.
[inaudible] booked legion of skanks.
You know who they are legit people
who hold the rose and Luis, right?
Luis, Luis Gomez and Gomez
and uh, Dave Smith and they,
they're hardcore guys except when they
come on this podcast plus out. But like,
um, the hardcore guys for the
most part, so they booked,
they bitched out on the day.
I don't understand that.
I thought we just had a conversation.
[inaudible] that's fucking,
I'm actually jackass in that heyday
of jackass and them all sitting here
politely and not trying to fucking shave
their heads in front of, it's like,
come on dude. Obviously they need a second
chance on this podcast. Thanks. Not now.
Not on you. I wouldn't get
one. These expectations come
up and do something crazy.
I'm like, come here. Had a
good time with you. Yeah. Fun.
Nice car. Nice conversation.
But it's funny. [inaudible] I know it's
traceable to drink some tea. They said,
let's talk a Milo Yiannopoulos
and Milo said they cooked down.
So now ours running with the narrative.
Listen,
so they booked Milo. They're like, oh,
we have this guy who's been
fucking whatever. And then uh,
and then everyone started going doing
the thing with the attack, the venue,
if you have that are ready, the problem
is not enough that they can miss,
analyze the person or say,
I want nothing to do with that guy.
Then if you put him up,
then you're the issue.
Or a woman who gave birth to tons of
fucking great LGBA and fucking black
performers.
She's an issue because she's not
stopping or a performance from happening.
And then soon it will be like if
you're performing at that venue,
then you're an asshole. Right, right.
You know, it's nonsense happening.
What's the ACF for lesbian,
gay, bisexual alliance. Oh,
they have a lot more since I left
college, but that's what I was told. Yeah,
that's a problem is when you look at LGBT,
which is like the accepted
use of those letters.
We didn't have to add college to
a, in the end we were like, oh,
a is now asexual and fin Taylor does
a great joke where it's like they're
included, but it goes, the reality
is the asexuals hate the other ones.
But like you're disgusting.
I don't care what kind of sex or having
lesbians are not really excited about
transgender men or transgender
women rather true. There's that.
There's turfs you know trans exclusionary
radical feminist. No, I don't know.
Busy fucking live in my life
and trying to fucking dominate.
You're trying to dominate.
Try to dominate. Damn.
I didn't know you were trying to dam.
Can you fill me and more on this though?
So tell me about Dominic
not leave dominating.
I want to write that down,
but there was a big uproar.
A lot of comedians started trying to
like show how they were woken up and
they're like,
I don't think you should do it.
Who have penguin very publicly quit
putting her, Becca in this position
was going to be in.
Here's how you can tell someone
who's a fucking white knight virtue.
Signaler when they don't go to you saying,
Hey, Tom, I'm calling you on the phone.
Don't do this, but I get it.
I might not have your number,
so if I'm tweeting at you,
I'll just write at Thompson Guerra.
Don't do this. If I really want
to virtue signal, I'll go dot.
At Thompson Goro Hey, at Thomson Reuters.
So it's not just me and your followers.
Everybody, anytime anybody
sees, if you're listening,
you see somebody not start with the APP.
That is them virtue signaling
on purpose and all these comics,
unless they're saying something positive,
they just wanted it. Oh yeah, yeah,
absolutely. That's you're right. Good
point. Like, hey everybody, come see Tom.
You know? Yeah. You don't want
to say Steve. Suppose fear.
I loved you knew Netflix specials.
Yeah, I'll let her the Jew hour. Yeah,
it's coming. Um, it's great. It's
great hour everyone. I saw it.
I saw some of like tower. He's
been working hard. You Buddy Milo,
he's going to appear on the show.
All these comics,
all these people started saying,
I will never go to the creek again.
She put unbelievable pressure on her.
They call him a Nazi club owner, Jewish.
And he's also married to a gay man who's
black Mack who was black [inaudible]
his ass opens it up gently.
So wait a minute, what ends up happening?
So they go, we're not going to happen.
Okay. So they said, we're doing
this, we're not talking about,
they started going to war with these
fucking virtue signaler comics. Okay. Um,
and then at some point, Rebecca, I
talked to her a bunch because I don't,
this is not my thing. I don't even
want to do it. And I'm like, Becca,
what you do is you stand by your comics
and so you let them do whatever they
want. Obviously I've been on the road,
I mean I've been on the wrong side.
I've had venues cancel me. Yeah.
Cause of Shit like this. So I'm like,
you don't want to be involved.
Then Milo's people said, oh guys,
you put out the, the time and date of
where I'm going to be, I can't go anymore.
So they moved it.
So they moved to instill,
did it and still did it somewhere
else. Yeah, we did it. And then, okay,
it's a shout out to her
for not caving then. Yeah.
Consider names a creek in the cave.
[inaudible]
yeah. So that, did it go out? Oh yeah,
10 no, no. Okay. Yeah. And it's, it's,
it's all,
I didn't watch the whole thing,
but the part with you and Milo pouring
booze, it was, it was pretty funny.
The next time somebody calls Milo
a Nazi and me and Nazi sympathizer,
they said to my face,
oh maybe I'm just weird,
weird cause I just saw my dad
speak at the memorial. But Mike,
if you're going to tell me the
people who took his father,
and so you need to say
goodbye to your son and son,
you've got to take care of the family
down and watch the rest of your family
fucking disappear in death is the
same as that political analyst.
I'm going to slap you. You
should slap. I should. It's so,
it's so derogatory and offensive
in a way that I'm not okay with it.
So you can say that away from me, but
if you say it to me, I'm going to,
there's a lot of Shit [inaudible] that
we're saying that there's not enough of
those guys.
You're getting smacked smack and that's
what he has always said things we good
snap, delirious, delirious.
Completely ridiculous.
It's insane. It was crazy.
Is a provoca tour.
He fucks with people.
He pushes buttons and he does. So
in the age of the Internet. Yeah,
he's great troll.
The thing that they got him on,
which is where it all got really weird,
was essentially him saying
that it should be okay.
What happened to him when he was molested?
That he was abused,
sexually molested by priest
and this priest, he, you know,
he would joke around and say that he was
the one that pursued the priest and he
was, trust me, I was the Predator
like that. That's how he said it is.
He's hilarious.
And that's what got him.
It was talking about that on my show
and then talking about it on this other
show, wasn't it? The amazing
atheist show was right.
The point is that anybody who says like
you shouldn't be allowed to put that
person, she can't be heard
anymore. That's what you're saying.
But that's what it was.
But it was really just his harsh critiques
of Liberals and feminists that were
so biting.
And then you know,
he actually did a podcast with Jordan
Peterson recently. We talked about the,
the,
the molestation.
I didn't see it but from
Jordan's explanation it's
like he's understanding now
as he's older that yeah,
he was
a victim of this thing and he was
making it less and less full. Yeah.
Yeah.
That he was giving this guy like,
like a pass that he did it to him
almost. Yeah, I agree. The cricket,
the cave was a great place for your
comics in New York because there's always
like, I hear nothing but great
fun. Plus it's like they, they,
they bring together young comics and like
give a place to perform with no one's,
it's, it's, it's, it is
what the comedy store was.
If you take away the side
effects of the 12 plus your cost,
how many seats is it? 80 on top
and 1520 on the bottom. Jesus.
Oh, do I walked in, I walked him.
This is my impression of this place in
one time I walked in with Shane's only
skank fest. Yeah. And I walked past
already throwing piss on somebody's.
Oh Nice.
Yeah.
And I walked downstairs to a room full
of people with their shirts off chanting.
Uh,
do you remember that Orry teaching?
Did you chit in a Tupperware there?
That's where you opened it
in the Tupperware dictate
sound shit in a Tupperware
and then opened it up in the room.
It was a tackle boxes that fishing things
person like little was outside and he
was like, I ran it, smelled it
from fucking down the street.
I'm starting to gag just,
and these guys were offended
by [inaudible] just shit
into it and see whatever
happened happened. It was a pile
a bit. Oh my God. The question,
I'm not sure exactly.
Sometimes when you shit,
it smells awful and you realize you've
shit so much. It's broken water.
It's rising.
Like
why out of the fucking toilet bowl?
You know,
it's like the Kona coast mount. Like,
why does it smell so bad? Human Liddy
realize human shit so bad, Mike.
Dog Shit doesn't smell nearly as bad.
Fuck.
Not even nearly as bad as people
should that people should discuss.
It smells like hate crimes, dog
shit. Once it gets in between,
your toes smells worse.
Don't believe that dogs aren't drinking.
That's what it is. I'm not
drinking whiskey. Eating subway,
dog hydration.
Water mixed her shit.
Good guys on a dog has a new product.
We have a problem with dogs.
[inaudible] Shit.
Dehydrate your dog nearly as bad.
Not Nothing's as bad as humans. Shit
so nasty man. You know you what?
You're walking like in a city,
you still see shit and then say it.
Say if you just smell it,
you smell it.
It's like a fucking 90% chance.
Oh, how much? Shit. You know, dude,
that's what he told me in Hong Kong.
They're like, listen, if you see, hold on.
Not every man lander from
mainland China shits in malls,
but if you see shit in the
mall, that's a mainlander. Yeah,
like they're disgusting. They just
shit in the mall. They just shit.
Mainland Chinese people
just shit in the mall,
like told him I like him in the bathroom.
So the ground, the ground's whole case.
You're walking through the mall and
you see human shit on the ground.
They don't know how to be
Chinese doors are underrated.
There's tourists in the world. Chinese
stores, the worst tourists when they're,
when they're saying the Trump,
we're going to hold up tours and back.
All the fucking travelers
like please keep.
They are so they just,
some folks who live in rural,
China's aligned to the children.
You've been there but it hot these shorts.
He's wide shorts with a cut down the
middle. So when you're open, stand up,
the cut comes together when you squat,
so you don't have to fucking
lift your shorts out.
It comes out and then just shit
away. Shit. Where they're walking.
10 year olds wearing his shorts.
How do I get those pants for Sundays?
What is this? Why kids keep crapping in
public in China is part of their culture.
Dude. [inaudible] Shit. And you can
find anything online. These shits.
That's true. Let's look at Burt
with the fucking common sense, dude.
I'm getting treated and
worse doors, flip sides, acid, Chinese,
tourists and not poop on the ground.
Oh my God. Rolled down that for
a second. Five words. Tourists.
Chinese far and away number one like,
like fucking Richard Pryor.
Chinese replaced Americans as the worst
tourists in the world. We never work.
They're obnoxious. Oh my God. This is
a terrible article. Although, although,
have you ever been a shit in public?
Apparently. Oh my God. This is on Vice Uk,
vice UK vice. How care but that
we're so we're reading this folks,
if you hear those words, I
have not said that. Yeah.
I'm reading something off of a UN.
The title,
I'm not saying technically are,
he did say everything
by Chinese towards it.
By far the worst tourist next day is,
I don't want to say this is real and
Russians tide. Why Israelis? [inaudible]
I'm bad. I'm bad. I'm missing
Australians. The bogans,
ours garbage people serious. I have
fucking inflicted him into the world.
Like go learn on their turf. Wow.
Bogans row off. Why is just get drunk?
I don't know.
How can I get out of the army and they
think they can fucking go nuts. Yeah.
I don't know. But people don't like
Israeli tourists. Really? Yeah.
They got a reputation about him.
Didn't know that Americans
are way down the line. No.
Americans are not celebrated in a lot
of parts where you traveled to man.
Very celebrated a lot of who were
the only ones who tip consistently.
Hardcore people like our money and the
ones who travel or not the fucking fat
rednecks gone and gone to the
world, but sometimes they are.
That's the church sometimes. So
there's a lot of merit. Saves.
Plenty of obnoxious Americans traveling.
Yeah, but we're not in this top five.
Really interesting.
I would have felt,
I would have assumed we'd
normally shitting at the
mall. I that's around town.
It's a big doors.
Is Insanity Dude,
like for you to think that other
people are going to be like, oh yeah,
just got to take your shit too still
right here where it's like I gotta Piss it
public.
Things like block me,
make block me around the time
so you don't have to block me.
I'm just gonna shit real quick.
It's like we're in the
woods that I got to Piss I,
there's no like embarrassed I level.
That's how they feel. I didn't feel, dude,
they don't even worry about who cleans
it up. Let it stay there. Do they lie?
There's no wiping. Everybody knew that.
If ever way you look to buy shit, ah,
Jesus. Oh wait, you're walking.
If you were to confront somebody,
like right after you look the fuck
did you just do, they'd be like,
do you think that they would confront
you with like what you just got in your
car?
Like what
do you think that it's where they're
living is so overrun with people that they
just shit anywhere and they don't
think that anybody has an [inaudible]
environment.
Well now you're asking me to speak
with an expert and I will not lie,
but this is all night
interpretation and yeah,
I think they have no
expectation of privacy because
they're so fucking on top of
each other.
Their homes extremely clean.
Take off your shoes
before you come inside.
The homes are fucking touching about
is this thing like mark? I'm not,
I'm saying main but
there's an on the mainland,
you know China is over a billion people.
So you have a lot of like really poor
Sean educated rural parts and like saying
that somebody in that area
does this. I'd be like, yeah.
Are you saying that like even somebody
that lives in Beijing or Shanghai who has
a job or Wall Street? No they don't.
No they don't. So that's why the tech,
not all mainlanders were shitting malls.
But if you see shit in the mall,
it's amazing man. Very clear. When
they say kids, what age group is it?
High school kids who were trying to
fuck or is it like just shit talk,
I'm trying to shut,
I wasn't in shock.
I was in Hong Kong, Singapore,
in Macau. So now the mechanical,
what's funny is when you were in Macau,
which is obviously big casino kind of
tourist destination, all the people there,
they eyeball immediately who
they'll tell you who's like a,
a mainland Chinese person, you know,
cause they can tell by the, well,
that's a different type of thing
where if there's, if somebody is like,
do you see dudes in Macau in like Versace
shades and like a Fendi and Gucci and
like, I mean outfits, crazy
outfits and you're like, God,
what's up with that dude?
And they'll be like, that's just
a mainland dude who a new money.
He just got rich. Wow. It's all
over Macau. And we just know.
And then you see that the uh, the
understated person, they're like,
that's a Hong Kong guy. That's old money.
Yeah. Right. Oh it's like England almost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But you don't
like, you not like England.
They got guys that are like
this or like tracksuits and water.
And then you got the old posh money.
All right. All we can do
accents, accent, challenge.
[inaudible]
don't fucking side Florida.
What's up guys? And fertilizer.
I got tornadoes.
Laurie. I'll say a country.
You do the accent without
saying the words. Okay. Okay.
Here we go. Russia don't say the
words. Just make the noises they make.
I'm not great at accents holes.
Oh, don't wish. Don't do
anywhere else. Any words?
You just
heard it.
The Samurai speaking,
Sasquatch footage. No. No.
One of the dumbest things that Duncan and
I did when we were doing that shot. No,
no, no. We went and studied bigfoot.
One of the dumbest things like Ari did
the show with me and one of the things
that we did when we studied bigfoot
was talked to a bigfoot expert.
Those plaintiffs, some audio and some
of the audio. It sounds like a Samurai.
It sounds like what the what and the
guy was claiming that this was like a
secret recording of big
foot. I'm like, you can ride.
It was the dumbest fucking thing I've ever
heard in my life. Anything. By the way,
in your conspiracy theories
and like what you challenge,
was there anything that you ended up
going, oh, like, oh, good question.
Not Dumb. Yes, really more challenge.
Disease or shower Gel Jaylin's diseases.
A disease where people,
is it more challenges? I was called
[inaudible] thank you both for it. Yeah.
I thought it was bullshit before cause
I had read that it was bullshit and what
I read was that the people would think
that they had things grown out of their
skin so they'd be scratching themselves
and they would add fibers to their skin
and take pictures of it and say,
look,
I've got things growing out of my skin
and that, that it was a hoax. But um,
then talking to a doctor who had more
Jerilyn's who explained to me that there's
some sort of neurotoxic effect of Lyme
disease and that everyone who has more
challenge also has Lyme disease.
And he was a legitimate doctor in a,
in a very smart guy. And
he was essentially saying
that mainstream science,
it's rushed to prove he's going to Piss
[inaudible] he's already starting to be,
come on man.
Yeah, but you're going to get us kicked
off of Youtube with your dick out balls.
Just cut straight to his day.
Anyway, what was I saying?
That that is a real disease, that this
more jealous disease is what it is, is,
is Lyme disease, the, there's a bunch of
pathogens that come with Lyme disease.
You know, it's not just the Lyme disease,
it's not like a pure one, you know,
like one or a zero.
You have or you don't,
it's a dirty tick as a bunch of fucking
horrible diseases inside of its nasty
little body. Would you know
if you had Lyme disease? Yes.
You get a bullseye like
well, like looking um, uh,
red mark around the area and the area
hurts and then you start experiencing
terrible
symptoms like flu,
like symptoms and okay.
You got to kind of bring up the re
supposed to catch it quick. Oh yeah.
On your show you want to brush his teeth.
And he's like,
he couldn't like go back and
forth. It was like, what the fuck?
My friend's kid got bell's palsy where
his face went and don't get me started on
my teacher that,
that had bell's palsy in high school and
they kept him out and then he came back
and he was okay bro. No. But he,
he came back while he still
had the face paralysis.
We're all like looking at this dude.
We had a student a year older than
me or bell's Palsy and we mocked them
relentlessly.
Look very [inaudible],
haven't got it on stage,
on stage.
And his face started going on him and
he had to hold his cheek over to finish
his jokes that he called his brother in
law. He was, I think I'm having a stroke.
I'm about to get on a plane and
I think I'm having a stroke.
The next morning his face was numb and
drooped in his brother in law goes,
go to the fucking doctor.
Right now you're having a 20 hour
stroke and it was bell's Palsy.
And so what did they do about
that? Nothing. Fucking nothing.
Just she just wait. Just wait. If
Tad it, dude, I get, I wake up.
Eddie if had it too. I think
it's a virus. You'd be good at it
because policy palsy every
fucking morning. Why? I
came home later that morning. Every
more ritual. Why you think of that?
It's my ritual. Every morning.
I got up early, I left,
I thought he was doing Stallone
impression. He said Bell's Palsy too.
He's got it when he was young and it
sometimes it doesn't go away. Whoa.
And so he wrote, so we're at about 40
moths. So is it affects the spelling or,
yeah, I don't know if he knew
how to spell it doesn't help.
So basically I,
she looks better now,
so I hung out with him this weekend,
but uh,
so easy back on stage and he's back on
stage and he spent like three weeks in
his sister's basement just being like,
it's never going to come back.
My career's over.
I can't go on stage.
Like he tried to do a show and he said
everyone was just staring at it like this.
Like, oh, oh mom. So what
do they do to fix it?
Nothing. You just wait. You just
wait until it starts coming back.
He said reboot was like right your
your face. So you got to get code. Um,
so why do you think about this
every morning, dude? Yeah.
Especially when I'm getting
ready for a special.
I think like what if I got bell's?
What if? What if I get jokes to tell?
The morning,
the morning of my special secret time,
I woke up and I smiled and I went, I
beat bell's Palsy. So first thought I had
Jesus Christ.
How am I involved in this conversation?
I can't believe I'm involved in
this conversation for bell's Palsy.
You know what else I forget? I think
of Alopecia, this hair falling answer,
everyone gets out every, there
was a hanging out. I was little.
Every comic at the store had it
burn, had it. I met, I met at it.
Everyone got it at one point
and I was just was like,
don't give all the hair fell
out just in in a circle. Norman it
comics, get it. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm had it and just trying to scratch
my head when I was a kid. Yeah.
I think about alopecia to Tyson had it.
Remember that's why he fought over and
Mike Tyson out of like a weird circle and
in his head for awhile. Yeah. Wait, you
said you were going to dominate earlier.
What do you do?
What you're saying through
like to dominate you gotta
give me the context again.
I know when I get up.
You like dominating,
dominating life. Yeah. Crushed. You
have time to dominate because you don't,
you know on your phone.
That's what it was. Yeah.
I can masturbate multiple times
a day instead of just once.
Like you guys like the
lady though, right? Yeah,
Dude. Honestly guys, it might
not be this year. You're married,
social media stuff.
Your wedding is next.
You're going to take that out of your
deck deck. Gay Shit taped back up.
I'm going to be like,
I made it gets you out of rock.
I can't to shoot some hot ones into you.
I love you so much.
I got my Dick Fixed, got
on my pipes, reconnected.
They pulled a straw out of one of those.
We'll see turtle's noses and
they use it to fix my dick.
You know this drive video with the sea
turtles knows it's the most horrific
video. It's the reason why they
don't have plastics brought up.
If you're like, why the fuck
do we have plastic cups? Lids,
why do we have plastic? You're going
to show water bottle. No, don't look,
why don't we have plastic straws?
The reason why is because there's a
fucking video of a turtle and they have a
clamp.
I don't know if this is the main reason,
but it is for a lot of people clamped
this straw in this turtle's mouth and they
eventually pulled it, pulled the turtle's
nose, rather it was deep in his nose.
So this, watch this. Yes, she can.
One of those. So see that's a,
that's a strong to tell you. They got
stuck in his seat. Turtle is harder.
It is so much harder to watch.
Things happen to animals into people.
How do we not know this wasn't a night
of cocaine gotten wrong? Look at that.
Poor Turtle. So he inhaled, oh
he's fucking good one. Oh fuck.
So they realized that the straw was stuck
and apparently this is not bleeding.
It's, this is not an unusual thing.
So they have to put up a wait,
what do they pull it out and tweets
or guy get a real tweezer guys scared.
He's scared and he's got,
he's got little hands too.
He's got little fucking tie hands.
Little bit shouts hands
grab it and pull them out.
This saving turtles assholes
about this person's hands.
Pour turtles going,
Jim Norton.
Jim Norton's going, no, don't do it in
a pocket knife. Well that's all he's got
to get it out. I would bite it with my
face and I would pull it out with my neck.
Cause you're a warrior. If someone
holds fucking care about the animals,
I care about the animals. I'm a warrior
for sea creatures. Oh, there we go.
This has got to get it. This got
to right the fuck now he's got it.
He's got a leather man. Oh, that
is like, no, this guy is horrible.
It takes horrible. Never wanna play
operation was his guy. It takes time,
but it's worth it at the end. Oh, he's
trying to bite the shit. He's like,
what are you guys doing? To
me it was fine. It's better
before. Leave me alone. Oh,
he's bleeding out of his fucking nose.
How did they get the sea turtle in the
boats and notice in the first place,
guys stop being a bitch. Grabbed her to
stop. She stopped biting at goes here.
He goes, nope. Nope.
Lost it. Fucking pull it.
You just got to jet eventually gets
it. Eventually gets it. I swear to God.
Show me. Show him getting it.
There's still much more hard. Okay.
The video is almost done, so
this is what hard. Oh my God.
They're going to take that out and
they get a stick it in Ari's Dick.
Hold the fixes.
Broken pipe.
That turtle they should do.
They should recycle it and use that to
open up your Dick Pipe. The flu shots.
They take that rock out. That
calcified Dick Rock. Yeah.
Make it a nice ring.
Oh,
for the little lady that is really
with the romantic damn pipe.
With the actual tube that they
pulled out of that turtle's nose,
that there was a diamonds
in there to fix your dead.
Go ahead and get rolling
it out. Yeah, why not?
What if we each raise at
dire wolf like something like
someone's drunk.
Oh my God. It's funny guy to
leave my car here. Yeah, for sure.
Call your side if you want.
If a car here do we gotta we gotta fucking
get your car straight what we were,
but we're going to put like all
those jokes on the side of your car.
Like do you like, do you like
to laugh? Oh, that's right.
Yeah, we can do that. Yeah,
we're going to, you don't have a
car, so it's tough, but a rental car.
Brand new car sale. That number.
Yeah, of course. My little rap.
Whatever happens through
what happens to it. Yeah.
We'll put a sober October
wrap on that bitch.
I said we all wrap our cars and
cars and sober October. Dude,
you're already have extra rap
rap.
I wrapped his bus,
wraps up my face.
It's so much fun. I put my face
on everything. The bus champ.
I didn't even tell you. Are you the bus
champer as are the tour bus chip? No,
you're not. What are you doing?
Art lymes disease. What is that?
That's close to what's
happening is wrong with you.
Is that poison ivy? You got poisoned. Hey.
Oh, you know what I bet would help you.
I bet some CBD oil rubbed some CBD
oil on that. What am I a doctor?
How'd you get poison ivy on your
camping trip with Bobby? Yeah. Oh Dude.
Fuck down. Catch us. Fuck Kashi. Shut up.
That's what everybody was [inaudible]
kicked catch. You can't catch him.
I can't use that stuff. I was like,
no, catchy. I'm like, you sure?
Why are you coughing man? Yeah. Why
did the guy next to you start coughing?
So was way fucked up.
Thing about diseases too.
Like they try to spread themselves
like they tried to, yeah, like alien.
I did a meet and greet in Spokane and
I'm doing it and the guy next to me,
the guy next guy rips his shirt off, puts
his arm around me and he was coughing,
burning on fire and I go, Whoa Bro,
you are hot. And he was like, yeah,
I've got a pretty bad fever.
[inaudible].
He's like,
yeah man,
me to think you're going to get it
to that is the perfect Burt fan.
Pretty bad fever and sick.
I wasn't going to get this giant fan,
but I'm taking my shirt off.
You're taking years off too,
and then he'd probably be
like, Hey, do you mind if we
kissed and bird be like, oh,
it's one of the things you'd remember
the other night we were talking,
I was drunk. I was talking about how my,
my inner dialogue is, you think I'm weak?
I would say, yeah, so one of the
ones is when guys go, hey man,
like it's always like a big Italian guys
picture you kissing me on the cheek,
kiss me on the fucking cheap. And I
always go, Nah man. Because in my head,
am I here? My brain does he think I'm
fucking week. I got to kiss me, kiss me.
The little teams, so buck
their coach, hey, I'm going
to look you fucking nipples.
I left them in their 20 [inaudible].
You run into a lot of weird people out
there with bells palsy for an hour.
Oh my God.
It'd be great.
You should get a shot botox in your
face for a month because that does work.
It's a good challenge.
I'm up for that challenge.
[inaudible] palsy challenge and raise a
where's awareness for both lady who shot
too much and it was like affected
her eyelid. Wow. Yeah. Be careful.
You get to the wrong doctor and they're
like, yeah, one more shot a little more.
And you're like, eh. During the
Mitsui [inaudible] smile at women,
just to make sure I'm
not having bell's palsy.
Imagine if your nose is running and you
even know to call them dumb. Oh my God,
Dude.
No,
I wouldn't mind a tiny face
tattoo. Yeah. This is what we do.
We're gonna all get botox
so we can't move our face.
You don't have to do your act. Do you
have to do your act like Joan Rivers?
I like with a, with a frozen
expression through this a show.
I really start doing shit with our
voices and that's the only in you'll have
your house at all. He can't raise
your eyebrows at all. There's a show.
Rivers had bits about it. Really? Yeah.
She has so much plastic surgery
for new about our plastic surgery.
She can't hide it. It was like
she was, it was like a mask.
She looked like a surprise catfish.
That's what's his name's Joe said that,
who's the lawyer?
The lawyer drawled up
the best is when he told us he told uh,
flavor flave you look like a skeleton
with duct tape wrapped around him.
Um,
I forgot everybody challenging Bob's
or challenge. It should be hip hop.
We have another hour.
We have another I thought of when you
start getting a move down you're like, oh,
why? But so wait, what do you like?
It should be something that we can do on
the road because we're all gonna be on
the road barefoot running.
I'm telling you this,
it might not be this year and
it might not be next year,
but eventually you guys will
come into my idea of metal.
I have mental health
check with Joe was saying,
and I don't think this is a bad idea.
I'm saying Joe saying this,
obviously it is a conversation we had,
I don't know if you want to show this,
but he was saying we were
backstage and he was like,
it's not bad to do another
one of these halfway in.
So if you want to do
another like do like a May
Sobrato something with May and do for
you at home listening. Absolutely.
You should do that if on your own terms.
I'm cool with anything we decide.
I just think it should be hip hop
dancing and we should do it twice a year.
Okay. Just wait, wait, wait,
wait. One other thing. Shoot.
You were saying earlier
how your body moves,
so I want to know like are you flexible?
Are you super flexible? Very,
yeah. Showing how flexible
are you? Please do this.
We touched your hands behind your back.
Of course.
This way. Stupid behind Joe.
Can you, let's see it. Can
you, can you do the splits?
I can just split. Show us at the
table right now. Can you do a split?
He can do a split. He only buys jeans
that have like written. All right,
so let me show me how to do a split first
and then I'll show you if I can do a
split. Listen, I don't want
to get it a muscle pull,
so I'll go down as far as I can go
with same hours. Same here. Yeah,
you do the same. Why don't you guys
just save time and touched dicks now.
All right.
Okay. There we go. Nope. Nope. Oh fuck.
Oh my dick is about that far off the
ground and I think if he didn't have the,
I think if he didn't have jeans on the,
okay.
The gravity would take as thick all the
way to that. Okay. All right. All right.
That's legit. Yeah, Bert. Yeah.
And you want me to go that far?
I want you to go farther if you can. So
now wait a minute. Pocket. Yeah, yeah,
for sure. Now, if I was
at the end of Yoga class,
I can definitely split.
You want me to go all the way down like
you did? Yes. Yeah. Okay. Ready, Bert?
Those pants are not even
designed for that. Guys.
Let's keep rolling.
Keep Rolling.
Took your shoes. That hurt. I'm
hurting myself. I got to tell you,
that was really close a lot for this.
This is the exact conversation we had all
month last October. We got a knee down.
That's pretty good. Fuck. Are you
saying man to look, here's the deal.
What's the deal?
I'm not going into sober October half ass.
I'm definitely charging every
one of you motherfuckers.
Just like I did last year.
You can't show up one of the shittiest
all time specials of all time with even
shittier. Yeah. You gotta like what
do you say something better saying no.
Whenever we decided to do, I'm still going
full tilt said you did that last year.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Last year he was awful and
he's going to come back strong,
but he was saying he's going to come
after us like he did last year. I think
I'm drunk. Listen, hear me.
Okay. I'm going to talk shit.
I'm not gonna not talk shit
this year. Interesting. Okay.
No, it can't work anymore.
Right. But that's why when I do it
and they show affective Mickey Mantle,
not dead making is about it.
I ran it literally,
literally Mickey Mantle is acknowledge
that I have the Mickey Mantle Jean.
She acknowledged it
makes time say like shit,
like managing what does that mean?
And my dad spoke at the memorial and
the Holocaust memorial and I so badly
wanted to talk about people who died of
disease and stuff like that that has a
lot of people and I wanted to yell out,
they didn't have the Mickey Mantle
[inaudible] my God, I did a,
I did a date,
I dunno recently and there was with the
promoters that you work with now and so
you work with like one promoter.
He's Bro. You've worked with,
you've worked with the
promoter. Yeah. Yeah. We all
do. Okay, keep going. So I was
not going to buy the one for motors.
What he's trying to say. Yeah.
The Mickey Mantle told Mickey went up.
It's like a single guy we got. Yeah,
we were hanging out with your girlfriends
like fucking, anyway, she's got one.
He's got this one guy,
he's got this one guy.
He can't get a call.
I guess I'm your promoter Bert.
Oh yeah.
I just want to tell Ya.
I heard Tom talking about the promoters
and it may be proud that I'm get
promoted. They fucking, I know
that there's someone else.
There was someone else you would,
I mean you wouldn't be that hurtful
that you would be referring to someone
else's. Your promoter. I start sweating.
I don't want to be, they brought up the
gene and they were like, I've done it.
I've done a bunch of dates with
him and I tried to hang out.
No one can keep up. They're like, I
can't do it, man. Booze. Yeah. They like,
I can't answer that with very few people
can keep up with my pace on the road.
Mark Marin or Mark Mark Norman audits.
I was worried about,
I don't know if I can come up
and don't try to be normal.
He broke them fucking 40 days at nightly
try. I don't know. It's just, it's just,
I don't even notice already 12 no,
no, no, no. I'll say, why did he try,
why would he try to get you
both said you go on your pace,
just be with 100% it was that guy's name,
the promoter.
You're all one guy.
All right,
so
I think we all agreed that the surfing
challenge was too crazy, right?
I was dom [inaudible] idea.
I was thinking it might be a fun
idea that like the board no out.
But here's the thing, it's like I
don't live anywhere in New York.
Fucking you're going to be
in the and got your own shoe.
You live near New York and
you live near La Long Beach,
but like you're going to be on the road.
Oh fucking whatever. Where do people,
we were dancing, art, dancing, dance.
I don't know why,
but a little bit fucking somewhere there.
Think about you walk on stage,
boom.
The lights come by you right?
Another way it comes down, right?
The music starts and you start boom,
boom, boom, and then be like, oh shit.
And then the, the beat breaks. And
you go into something else and you do,
you learn how to flip in this month.
No. You've already bought 45 minutes.
Lots of gift. Interesting. 25 terra Joe.
Interesting. You're in,
you bang out a split.
You guys are high. There's no way that get
us to be able to do splits in. Dude. I,
I gotta be dead honest.
I really didn't think you could do a
split that's walking. I no, I didn't.
I well cause that's what I do. So yeah.
You really didn't think you could
do a split though. I didn't know.
I mean had to split a grown up
doing it splits tough. Yeah.
You got pretty not that close to you.
It was good. Do you think you'd be,
let's get some pictures of me doing the
split. Yeah. Multiple ones. Who's posting?
Can you sit criss cross apple
sauce and your legs. Art? Yes.
Oh look at his toes.
Striding there. By the way.
Look spasming till the one picto
is way, way all ears. Yeah.
That's not what I'm doing.
I'm pulling my feet up so that I
can push down with my hips. Like,
I'm the Washington Post and the
other toes assume in a quadrant form.
Like I'm foreign language on this,
I'm doing this, I'm spreading.
If I spread my feet out like
more played out in quadrant,
lifting my toes up instead
of pointing them down.
That could be you at doing that
so I can lean in with my crotch.
So you stretch the abductor adductor
muscle guys, guys gymnastics.
Hmm.
Good luck. This guy breaks his hip every
time he fucking gets out of the shower.
Yeah, I would delay to try.
How's the Israeli gymnastics?
He can't do gymnastics.
He won't be able to do anything
with that hand for like a year.
They second squeeze a ball at about 19
months. Yeah. Are you serious? Wait,
where's your break? Where's
the break? It's okay.
So on this side it's the bone here.
Chipped off and just free falling.
[inaudible] it's Tom Petty there and the
other one on here that they have a up
con I can push in break that they're
normally only see in like young children.
Uh, I told him I a lot of gummy related
products and he goes, that might be,
that could be for sure. That could be
part of it. So two different breaks.
And this is from a fall or was it pretty?
It was pretty useful in one
children and young children.
They've unformed the bone. Dark,
dark, developing. It's like a,
it's like a compression pounds don't form,
right?
Possible break at 13
months. Yes. Our fold. Yeah.
Sorry, what already was hauling ass?
Okay. Gymnastics is out. Literally.
This is good challenge. Let's look
at this. And he broke his arm. Yeah.
Ski Challenge.
Fucking shredding shit in front of him.
Shutting the normal would be the
challenge if we had a ski challenge.
We couldn't do it in October.
I guess it was how much you
guys could eat my dust and a
black diamonds. Do you go down both
times? Yes. Yeah, sometimes. Yeah.
You like a legit skier? No,
I'll skip this for you. Ari.
Ari is already in the woods,
is fearless and he can go down
anything but it looks disgusting.
It's like,
it's like watching your parents fought.
It is like he snow plows the entire
time just like pizza pie like this,
but he hauls fucking ass. You
haul, ask no plan. Six hours.
The miles and hour Joe.
I see a bubble. I'm like,
I'm hitting there and I fucking jump.
Get Air.
That's why you're always
breaking things. Yeah. Yeah.
Couple of things you call a
call up your notes again. Yeah.
What do you need this to the
last note? I said dominate. Yeah.
Banks see broken.
What have you broken?
An ankle and a broke two years.
Tow chasing a dog.
That doesn't count.
That's something I poison ivy.
This as who's a sixth year?
Like a Badass gear Costa.
No, that promoted the Burt
word with [inaudible].
Ah. Oh my God. I'm gonna Pass.
Ah. Oh my God. We have to,
we have to figure what out,
man.
I really think that that direction I'm
going in with hip hop dancers the right
direction because it Joe, it puts you
on our plane field. What is your planes?
Hit play, dance explained to me this. No
one's playing field. They don't like it.
It's something someone's already done.
That's why even if I did this,
I would have to go further. I don't like
about the uh, hip hop dance challenge. No,
I liked that one. We play
that again. The running one.
Yeah. I feel like we already, we
already know how it's going to go.
We know how it's going to go dominate
true track miles. Is that
what we would do, right? Yes.
We get the rocks or no, it's going to go.
Yeah. So that's, that's the way, way down.
How do you guys think it's going to
go? No, there's just no thinking.
We already know how it's
going to go. Thank you. Nope.
Cycle over here would fucking do.
He'd logged. I'd be, which one?
2100 miles.
Everyone's going to die and then he weighs
a fucking buck 35 so halfway through
the month he'd be like, you know, I can
actually do 10 out of fucking chop now.
And then you'd break down and they
get mad at me for doing steroids.
He brought me up at the comedy store.
So that was the Lance Armstrong comedy.
There was so wrecked over
contest cause he was on steroids.
That was your introduction. Is that
what you said? The room just this comic.
So funny.
He wanna he want to fit fitness challenge
by on steroids with his friends.
I remember being with already when he
realized you were using steroids in the
car and he goes, not steroids,
testosterone replacement therapy
on top of that,
if I actually use steroids,
it would be even more ridiculous the way.
What do you fucking chick drinking
over here that will take it? Let's do
this.
I said we do an archery chairman now.
Hear me out.
Oh my God,
we could have the least amount of time
spent with your kids aren't wins. Uh,
I'd probably beat him.
Hang out with your kids.
Okay. I honestly, I'll, for
real, for real. No joke. I
don't mind the phone thing.
I'm stepping out catching on. I don't
mind the fitness hip hop challenge. Oh,
it would be a good weight loss thing.
Just the same as yogurt was like a
ridiculous thing about doing it to get you
actually want to lose weight. Huh? Lose
[inaudible] just tell you what you you,
yeah,
my skin and it's probably a lot of cause
the booze too and whatever else I do,
but like my skin looked good, I looked
good, I look good. I didn't hate the yoga.
Yeah. To be honest with you. For you.
I'll tell you that. Another component
you mentioned earlier that was,
I did this for like maybe 12 day stretch
at the end of the weight loss challenge
was nothing but water and that makes
you feel fucking amazing after it.
What do you mean?
Because I just wasn't,
we were doing the weight
loss battle battle and I just
didn't drink anything but
water for like almost two weeks and like
everything changes the way you look,
the way you feel.
Only drank water.
Terrible things dragging him right now.
Should see. I want to, I was making
a joke about my, my right arm,
just put shit in my body that I don't
want it to do is got a mind of his own.
He's just like, Yo, what the
fuck you doing? Asshole drinking.
Yeah. Diet coke, coke, orange
juice, anything but water. Right.
Most people. Yeah. I mean you're,
you're, you're usually for me,
I mean I can get by on a lot of
combination of coffee and water,
color,
water be fine.
I mean I still will have some other
things but I don't do it a lot. Jessica,
when you just do water though, we
you just drink water. You definitely,
after you get over the, what's
it called, like the, you know,
withdrawal or whatever. The other
thing is, you definitely feel good man.
I went a day without caffeine by the end
of the dad headache. I'll get, I get,
I remember that. I have a headache.
Yeah, me think I got a real headache,
which are all symptoms. Yeah,
that's exactly what it is.
I'm telling you not this
year, next year, whatever.
When when you do get off your phones,
you're going to have those same
withdrawal symptoms. No, you're right.
You're right. For sure. I got back on my
phone. I was on the tour bus off my phone.
We were texting about some
bullshit and then I was like,
I'm hopping on Twitter and I
got on Twitter and it just,
it became my life. Right.
Again, like it just, I like dipping. I
cannot dip tobacco. Why? Because if I do,
you're right back,
right back in.
Yeah. For a long time. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. I miss it so much.
Florida. We'll do it to you. That's
why I started to it. But you drink.
But people who are dealing with after
you dipping's worse for you then,
then definitely not good for you.
Good for you.
I love that fucking burn right here.
Oh,
you slap people know you ain't thinking
that good. It's a nice little signal.
It's a, you got a big fat and
fat lip, a dip. You let them.
People know you're making a rash
and people know you're strong.
You're ready for anything.
Zach Galifianakis used to go on stage at
the Improv of the dip in his mouth did.
Anyways, Carolina got a
fucking, I swear to God,
he'd go on with a big dip and it's not
just spit and he tells the people that he
had didn't get [inaudible]
was so much fucking fun. Yeah,
he was a great though.
Miss him as a conduit is hilarious.
Did you see him at Brody's? Oh my God.
And Oh, he brought Brody at a party.
Nobody's calling. Jeez.
Probably past, yeah. I got
Zach to tack was amazing. And he
was, how exactly how king, yes,
but go ahead. No, his, I
mean, his stand up was,
it was all amazing. I used to love
watching him super tight with Brody,
Miss Air Jack, my wife. My wife
doesn't think anything's funny.
Zach Alpha next had a joke that I, to
this day, I think is just a great joke.
You know,
it's time to get lunch.
You know it's time to do laundry when you
get out of the shower and dry off with
the shoe to fucking just great.
Then I'll never forget where he was. Like
dork fabrics, like, what's your name?
Joe called and it's like, uh, what,
what's your name, Bert? Fuck you.
I don't know where at the Improv
go. Paul Shat. He was funny.
It was at Brody's ceremony. Not as funny.
He's Jeff Roberts, Jeff Ross, Jeff Ross,
Mike God. Jeff. Well Jeff, but,
but well Zach's was like touching and
sweet and funny and it was like everything
you'd want at Ross just came up there
and just see everybody was so kind of,
you know, sad, intense
and emotional opened.
His opening joke was so
savage and hilarious.
Brody's Brody's Brody's high school
friends had gone up like seven of them and
their school and then friends from
baseball, like telling all these like,
so there was,
you know,
you see Zach and then like three of
these friends and then another comic and
then like three of these friends. And
then Jeff just went up and he goes, uh,
you know,
after hearing so many of Brody's high
school friends come up and speak about
them,
I know why he killed himself,
the place of just his body.
He had to wait like 30 seconds to talk
cause everybody just fucking, it was easy.
It was much.
That's the,
that's what really comedy is best at.
Definitely Jeff is,
he's so good at so yeah,
that's his world.
Boston the best. He's
the best at it. Yeah.
Fuck so no hip hop dancing boys.
But I don't know dude. I honestly,
what you're going to see Joe,
is you're going to see an onslaught
of people online going to Joe hip hop
dancing, thought about I, this
is where you and I differ.
I'm not going to see shit.
That's why I'm so happy.
Go ahead and give him positive
and locking. Let me see.
Pop and lock to pay its way out the door.
You ain't got to like vanilla ice.
Hey,
take my care much about that with you.
Ah,
so it should be something that none
of us are happy with. Not at all.
I'm not happy with this show.
I think,
I think the fun thing about Chubb
Rocktober when we first did it was that we
were all miserable together. Joe
Wasn't so miserable, but like me,
you and Tom would all just
commiserate. That was fun. Well,
I didn't like being sober. It was weird
and uh, I didn't like, um, the, uh,
the weird dreams and I was having,
when I was going through Tfa,
THC withdrawals when my rem sleep was
kicking in, that's what I've realized.
That t that TAC definitely
suppresses rem sleep. Definitely.
You think it does 100%. It's proven. It's
proven. It does. It does something weird.
Your sleep and a math doctor,
Matthew walkers,
a sleep doctor. It's best
way to describe it. Right?
So I listen to that podcast, crazy
podcast, but you know, he did,
you talked about it. The mechanism,
like what, what THC does,
it helps people go to sleep,
but there's certain parts of the
sleep that you're not getting booed.
I'd love to. There's an officer, there's
an argument that, that not getting it,
that not getting that sleep is okay.
That you're,
you're getting plenty
of sleep because you're,
you're the reason why THC puts you in
that dream. You recovering and you get,
there's an argument that somebody made
online that, I don't know if it's correct.
Some someone wrote an article about it
that, that that is okay to not get that.
That's a good point.
Whatever kind of sleep that came from
the THC or let's see who can sleep the
most in October. I think leave
that idea. Love that idea.
Most of the hours sleep and
you take ambien. No, no, no.
Do you take anything to go to sleep? No.
I'll take a Xanax every now and then. My,
my cardiologist told
me never to take them.
So I'll get a prescription for 30
for a year and I won't use them.
He tells you never take them
cause I take 30 no, no, no.
He gave me a prescription. But you
didn't use it. He goes, I'll take them.
They melt your brain. Oh my God. Yeah.
You know what's so funny is they
do melt your brain. You can tell.
So if you take one the next two days,
you know when you're young,
I remember morning radio, like old
school morning radio. When you go in,
you have to be on,
on to go to the next subject and slide
your joke in and you're like leaving and
going, God damn and I'm
sharp. Take a Xanax and that
doesn't happen for two days.
You can't jump in and conversation
like that. Oh Wow. So I won't fuck.
I noticed it because I was taking them
and I just stopped and I was like, Oh,
I'm a lot sharper.
Just fucking nothing.
So like if you would go on stage
and have to ad Lib something,
you just wouldn't have it in. Yeah. First
time I ever took one I got on a plane.
I'm thinking, cause I used to have a drink
on the plane and start writing jokes.
I took a Xanax and all these are going
to flow out of me and I just sat there
staring at the paper going
like my brain's turned off.
All the fucking scary thoughts are
gone. Fuck taken. What? Xanax? Yeah,
that's a great one. I believe I
have to pee again for real. Yeah.
I do too many podcasts in a row.
We'll I do two in a row.
I drank like 18 bottles of water.
I'm in love with lamps,
Armstrong's fucking coffee.
It's Laird Hamilton's quality coffee.
[inaudible]
coffee I've ever had.
How's he? So it's, it's
actually as an r in there.
Turmeric, turmeric, turmeric
and what else is it?
I didn't know it at an r in
there until like a week tomorrow.
It's always sounds like tumeric.
That's, I thought it was termed rubric.
I thought it was too Marette. Yeah, come
by in the morning. Coffee and take off.
Is that cool? Yeah. Yeah. Anytime. So
good luck. Yeah. Cool. Yeah, let's,
let's put parameters around them because
there's so many times I want to come
over here and just do bench press for
anytime you want. Where Road here? Yes.
Joe says every once in awhile, several
take advent. He'll be like, whatever,
come to UFC or whatever you
want that someone would be like,
can I get every single one this year?
Like fog.
But that's a [inaudible] have
been people who do abuse things.
Like I've had people to say, hey man, I
want to come to the UFC. Oh yeah, sure.
Can I get eight tickets?
Like,
hey for eight fucking tickets now.
Fine.
I wish there was a gym membership here.
What to Rug in enterprise and let
me know. Let me know and I know, but
you can do it at what? Journal? Podcasts.
Like the guys, the security guys,
they work out. Just go work out and
see them on there. It's like fuck it.
It's like watching alien here. What do
you like? Where are they in the ship?
You can like see them everywhere.
It's so cool here, man. Rad. Dude,
I want to create this for
myself. You can. I'll help you.
I'm talking to my promoter about
it. That guy, what's his name again?
Roger. Gotcha. He's a great guy. His name.
Oh, you know what? This place
was missing a gun range.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to go to one like one of them
gun ranges where the fucking paper comes
out. Yeah, we do. There's a,
there's a place here that does a,
what's it called? Laser tag? No, no, no.
I placed it does, what's it called that
does a training. Tactical training.
Yeah. Watts. You're going
[inaudible] going. Yeah,
and Simi Valley. You guys want to come?
Yeah, I think that might be the place
to go training. That might be
any of that. But that's it. Yeah.
Reggie and I are going to do it and then
we're going to do a podcast afterwards.
So did he invite you to do it at Reggie's
from Montana? You know, he's like,
he knows God. Can I tell you something?
Have you ever seen him perform live?
It's crazy. His music just perform.
Yeah. Just like on a 13 him,
you ever see him do a show?
Crazy.
You will feel like what you
do is nothing is not a talent.
Like is not as skilled. I'm not kidding.
Yeah, I've seen, I saw this dude do a,
this is years ago. This is like
at least seven years ago. Yeah.
Maybe eight years ago he did that 10
at most 15 minutes set and it was so
unbelievable that he got a,
like a prolonged standing ovation.
I fucking 10 minutes set
like, you know crazy. Your 10
minutes set has to be,
what was he doing dude?
He was like just improvising songs
on the spot and then you know, he,
he would do that thing where he would
make a certain sound and then with the
machine you tap it and then
loops and then start building it.
And he would do that and then he would
just have like a funny aside about
something then take it back. But the,
the songs he was building in the moment,
we're so like, it wasn't like he
was going like, you like that.
I mean it was like a full orchestra. Yes.
And it was like you see it and you go,
there's something about musicians that
when you can see a certain musician where
you like, you don't view a
comedian where you go like,
oh my fucking God, I cannot believe
the level of talent to that person.
You might think they're
really funny or laugh a lot,
but you're not going to be
like, I've never seen something
like that. Right, right,
right.
With music,
I think that that can happen and
he's that everybody up at Bonnaroo,
a place where everybody was bombing,
just attend. It's not for comedy anyway.
Got Everybody on their feet. Like he
just has a power. Yeah. He's like,
he's like that. Yeah. Super Nice guy too.
But you're super [inaudible]
puts you in the crowd.
Like it was not talking to you.
You're just,
you're also like now you're standing up
and doing whatever. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I talked to somebody that went on a tour
with him like around that time and it
was like four, four of them a night, you
know, like doing like 10 cities together.
And I was like, what order did
you guys pick? He was like,
what do you fucking think
last fall?
Someone who's like really good at
music. Cause if I go just talk. Yeah.
They used to have a problem with that,
with middle acts like that.
That was one of the things
that happened with um, with uh,
Mitch Hedberg said Mitch Hedberg was on
the road and he had the Middle Act was a
guy was doing like wraps. He had
like wraps and songs and sync things.
He would sing and he was crushing.
And then Hedberg we're going afterwards
and Edward's like super deadpan and that
is the worst scheduling ever.
Like who fucking book?
Do you ever have a Middle Act who in a
club who just stayed in middle act but
for like 15 years but became super
proficient at doing 20 minutes and you're
like all that stress I can do.
Oh yeah,
it'd be like a guy who was like,
you know, he became an older guy.
You know what I'm talking about?
Oh Man. But it's like two days.
Johnson, Roy Johnson, Roy [inaudible].
I don't think he's not standing anymore.
What's your promoters?
[inaudible] was a Munster all stage in
Tampa and you could no fucking follow
that guy.
He was a monster.
He quit doing comedy celled
cars and Tulsa now. Yeah,
he was. You could not the bottles
that mother fucker saved Tripoli,
Tripoli and him had beef because they did
a show together and there was a secret
shopper in, in the audience. He's hired
secret shoppers to rate the community.
Tampa and then Roy Roy aid,
I mean, yeah, no, he does. I remember
I had him, he was a hard guy to Paul.
You've worked with them and to those guys
like I'm better than the headliner and
you're like, dude, I can't
disagree with you 100% right. Yeah.
Well that's usually the things don't
go right when you're keyed into that,
like why don't you get in and on Thursday
you see that it definitely raises your
game for the whole weekend.
Yeah, for sure. Oh for sure.
Because you'll see it and
that guy will have that.
He'll be the guy that stayed in that city.
Fuck.
Did he quit and start selling cars?
If he's that funny,
cause it was a feature [inaudible]
on the head. He probably,
he probably,
if I remember,
I probably didn't start at like 20
or 22 and he was a little older.
What kind of also it's like wanting to
stay in town. Well I think, I think,
I don't know, relationship always make
it happen, Tom Friends with Roy. But no,
I think that it was the thing that
you get addicted to murdering. Mm.
And you don't grow past
murdering and you don't go like,
I'm going to go up and take
chances. Someone above the
headline or off stage. No,
I'm not shitting on Roy,
but he just destroyed.
But I don't think he ever
took the chance was like,
I'm going to go out and bomb tonight
and see if I can figure something out.
You know? I think that's ultimately
what happens with the features.
There's a lot of the men I
worked with all of them. Yes.
Some pro features for sure. And prophy.
I had one, I remember who he was. Uh,
he,
he's the story of the guy
who was headlining in those
clubs for like a decade or
more. Didn't like break out,
break out, but obviously it was,
he was like a proficient
comedian then like you know,
has like always has like somebody has
like personal stuff happen and then it's
like family stuff and you know,
for whatever reason then
they're like still in it.
But now they've been doing it like 25
years and then just needed to work.
So it would take middle weeks.
I mean,
you know those dudes would
fucking hurt you. Oh yeah. Dude,
for sure guys who really knew how to
crush knows basically they knew local
references and then they're just like,
and they've been doing it for
imagine 25 years and they're like,
just do 20 and and do it for like 10
weeks in a row of those things are
assassins foster care. If you're
tired of the material that I was like,
I'm sure kill, kill, kill your cocktails.
Yeah. The Boston guys for sure,
because those guys do 15 to 20 a night.
They do 1529 and then they
would do it like three times.
I'm in a row and then bring up
Billy crystal flip. I'm not joking.
Like Billy crystal ain't shit. Next calm.
He stopped that way. A lot of guys did.
They set them up.
It's rude.
They set up these like big name headlines
because Dale in a lot of it was like
jealousy. This fucking guy thinks she can
come here. Yeah. Yeah. And they would,
they would set them up, Bang, Bang, Bang.
They would put their biggest hitters,
Steve Sweeney, Kevin Knox,
Don Gavin, Bang, Bang, Lenny
Clarke, boom, boom, boom.
And then these poor bastards would come
in from out of town and these guys will
talking all this Boston talk and then
you've got a bullshit ass act anyway.
You know you're just kind of drifting
on you just in between movies.
So you do a little comedy. God,
make yourself feel good. Go Up,
see your adoring fans.
Hey yeah,
I'm just going to fuck around in Boston.
I'll just go down there and I
don't really have an act right now.
Piecing it together and then he
watch Gavin slash Sweeney smashing.
The fucking room is falling apart and
you see these poor guys like the look in
their eye knowing they were
going to certain death.
Nothing worse than following a crossover
black act crossover like crossover
black guy criss crossed up played a white
audiences. Oh were you just go up and,
and you're young and you're
like 32 for the race.
Taking the marketing fields where it
feels right. I don't know if it is,
but I'm still listening.
I'll just say his name
across bt would fucking,
I can't hold my piss anymore. Sorry.
Can't push a bottle right there.
Do you think, do you think the hardest
that you like the hardest active fault,
would it be like bt, bt
guys? Hardest hos. Okay.
Hardest Act to follow this [inaudible]
always do this but also the place,
so just to give you an example,
when I'm talking about falling,
Mike Marino got a fucking
fucking cop convention, you
know what I mean? I got it.
Okay,
go ahead.
I'm going to tell you the hardest weekend
I ever had in my entire fucking life.
Yes. I go to, I go to Miami and
still believe you. Nope. Already.
No I don't because like I
always saw him fucking like,
he's one of those guys that could
just at least kill.
Let's do well afterwards.
I get booked in Miami,
it's my first headlining week for the
Improv's and I don't sell any tickets and
they give me a call and they said we
need to bring in another comic who is
already in town to help you sell tickets
you doing right now. What are you doing?
I'm just taking my shoes off. And
your socks off. I don't know dude.
These fucking mushrooms.
She started, I thought they were
[inaudible]. Okay. I was like,
I'm sorry, I forgot that. I was like,
this is insane. And they're like, oh yeah,
the shoes and socks off
you pissing at the table.
You're taking the fucking socks
off. Oh, all right. Sorry.
So you're in Miami please.
I do want to hear this.
I just was super strapped
again. Keep going. So you're
in Miami. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
What happened?
They got another,
here's another comic in town and you got,
and he's going to co head line with you.
But the problem is he's already brought
his own feature cause he was, had,
he thought he was going to headline. So
who was it? I'll tell, I'll just tell.
I'll give you the line. I, okay,
so they go. So we've cut the host.
So we got your feature,
his feature him than you in Miami
in the heyday of Miami. Yeah.
The first day, I don't know
him, I've never met this.
This is like 85 yep. They go,
the breakdown,
the host is going to do a 15 the feature's
going to do 15 he's going to do 40
you're going to do 40 okay. Right.
That's a long show your life.
This was the intern announcements.
And imagine that the
hardest guy was to follow,
especially in Miami where everyone's
Spanish speaking. Ladies and gentlemen,
put your hands together for [inaudible].
Steve,
could I be in y'all,
Bert Kreischer dude,
I bombed harder than I've
ever bombed in my life.
I mean Miami sweat dripping
off my chin onto my shirt.
I don't say that to enable to bring,
I failed on that whole set and I brought
a black guy on stage and I brought a,
a Cuban guy on stage and I fuck, I go,
this is where the guy pulled his dick out.
No, that's the different night. But I
said to him, I go, Ugh, I'm going to just,
I go,
your people don't understand me.
So I'll say the joke and you
translate it to your people.
And so then she was sitting
on stage with me. So I go,
I was talking to this girl
and the black guy goes, man,
I'll spin game at this bitch.
And the place went nuts and
I sent it to the Spanish guy.
He just said it in Spanish.
I mean I put up, I put blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, whatever, and it's fucking
destroyed my whole act that way.
Whenever I had a joke I'd have them
translate it. They said and stay with you.
The whole sat on my stage for 35 minutes
and drank Tequila with me. That's good.
[inaudible] you're not
going to figure it out, man.
I've seen for being you to
straight course. He did.
Of course Freud number that you have
with your palms and you played it for
everybody. Tom's kind of have a
half memory of that and you know me,
I'm selling hot.
Yeah,
but I mean I played like clips
or like I'm better than anybody.
I wouldn't think it was good. Tom. Tom,
you've ever sat in the back of
a room with that was not good.
How about Sacramento?
That's the fucking worst though,
was the fun punchline
with it. What does it, no,
it was called the laugh laugh
unlimited last five minute ones. Yeah,
I like that place. Good spot.
When I was there I was like,
like you know what the worst thing about
I got bomb a bomb on a Friday night is
and that you bomb on the early show
and you can't believe how hard you just
bought. Like it's life altering. He
bomb hotter on the late show. Oh my.
They're both sold out.
So it's not like eight people.
It's like Oh my dad to the gills man.
What was the catalyst? The catalyst.
I mean he got me out cause
I remember that. I was like,
I remember everything my
life tonight. Like after you
know Jesus, it was that bad.
But then what was, what started
it? What started the bus started?
The bomb was the opening joke cause I
was just like, by the way, by the way,
before you tell your opening joke,
Tom is great with feeling uncomfortable
in the moment and taking it to the next
level. We're in Hawaii with Russell
Peters. The one thing they say is,
do not mention negative shit about
the Hawaiians. Tom's opening joke.
Do you remember it? And
they said, island life slow.
I didn't know they were talking
about your metabolism's. Holy Shit.
You guys are fat. You do the
same shit in Australia. Richard.
He's like that first word. Don't
mention Japanese people, man.
I got lost on base today. Luckily I ran
into a Japanese guy. He pointed me out.
They know everything about this base
is over there drinking his own pissed.
Oh my God, you got me for fucking fraction
of a second. I was like, no, he didn't
at it. I was like, he's
really locked, is fine.
He's drink his own piss.
So wait,
how did your mom go in Sacramento
to the Sacramento bomb was dirt.
It was the month after
the month after hurricane.
So I opened with a joke.
I don't remember the wording of it,
but it was like how there were,
um,
there's reports of people
raping people in the aftermath.
And I was like, yeah. I was
like, I opened, I was just
like, you know, nothing like,
uh, seen dead bodies float by that makes
me want to fuck somebody, you know.
And then I just kind of like
riff about like, you know,
dead people and then being like fuck.
And it would eat so much shit and then I
would go, you know, you have the thing,
you're like, well I just go to my
act now. Like I'll just go to like,
cause it was like, it was already too
late and I would bomb for the full,
the patching. And the funny thing
is they made the bowl shows. Yes.
Tell you what are you going to go?
There's something to this. This is funny.
I was like,
turn,
this is the why and nothing like seeing
a dead person on a TV floating by them.
It's just the timing,
the timing is off that fucking,
the club lady came, Leslie, you don't
like your new feature at a Clem.
I remember she came up, she goes,
they man, the bomb feels so bad.
Then you're sweating so hard and you're
like, man, this emotionally just taxing.
Right. You're just like, God damn right.
And I walk off stage and I
run like indoor. She goes,
I thought you were supposed to be funny.
Oh fuck she,
she goes to music read and I
go, what? And she was like,
you're supposed to do 25 you did 23
and I was like, I fucking all right.
And then like that's the first show.
Then the second show literally is worse
and an inconceivable way is worse.
Did you try to save that joke
again or try to open with it again?
This work and then I ate so hard.
Then I, here's Iheart, I eat it.
I eat it so hard that I'm middling and
the MCS like, damn dude, you fucking suck.
Like he's like, he's like, he's
like, you're like, he was just like,
it was that big dude. Yeah. He was
like, he was just like, God damn,
I've never seen anything like this. Fuck.
I was like, yeah, he was jovial. You're,
you feel like big lots. Yeah. It wasn't
my God. And then the next day I was like,
I don't know how I'm going to do this,
man.
And Burt coast couldn't give you one
piece of advice and I go, yeah, he goes,
open different, just do whatever you
want, but just opened on a different joke.
I was like, all right man. And
at the time I swear to you,
that fucking first show Saturday
by the best set that I've ever had,
like unbelievable set did. The lady
goes, oh, okay, no, no, no. She goes, uh,
I, I was, I felt redeemed, right?
Like I fucking destroyed and I will,
I mean like the MCS,
like Jesus. He said, I've never seen
a turnaround like that. You know?
It's like when I'm like,
this feels like I walk around and I see
her and I go like, then she goes, what?
I didn't hear anything.
I go,
she pretended like she didn't know shit
if she watched, I remember I grabbed her.
She kept coming up to me going, you said
he was funny. You brought them with you.
And I was like, trust me. The best part
about his bomb was Tom used to have about,
I lost amount of weight. I lost during
the sweating, all show you some longer
hair. And comb it back so it would
be up right. And as he bombed,
it starts to fall and then it starts
to get wet and then to run down,
I'm soaking wet. He's great. He
was like, I jumped in a pool,
like I was fucking soaking wet
that feel when you're eating shit,
it's not like anything else on earth.
I remember that. I remember that.
Like he was up on stage and
somebody yelled at him like
some late and he's like,
well you're a fucking dumb cut.
You said that. Yeah. And the,
and the room was like cut room turned out.
Yeah,
they'll turn on your car
then you want come back.
I remember him winning the back. I was
like, God damn. I used to have some uh,
some uh, quick go tos on
that. Yeah. Favors. Hey honey,
your mouth, uh, God made your mouth
for one thing and it's not talking.
That's good. God. What does that
mean? Math, I suck. So we say
that's a joke.
It's a irreproachable.
I would love to hear like a feminine.
This you say,
I should know this thing's flashing.
Flashing red. This one is too. Oh,
the recording is on.
You guys both had mushrooms said no,
they don't usually flash. Yeah,
I'm really do much. Oh Ass.
Are you the shoes off his shoes off?
I said the mushrooms are
to be shoes or something.
Then they got me a little bit for eat
them during the show ended right before
the show. Right before you start.
Right. I wasn't enough though.
What it likes essentially the Mo.
It's nice.
It gives you like a little nice thing
but like my palms are sweaty and I'm
fucking out of it. Yeah, definitely
sweating. Huh? Is that what it is?
You get your palms get sweaty guys.
Arm Spaghetti,
Spaghetti rap battle rap battle
rap battle rap daddy for help.
No, listen guys, I'm serious. It's either,
it's either type, no hip hop challenge.
Physically difficult though. It's not
totally different, but nobody do nothing.
That's the point already.
You want to watch people do stuff.
Have your play the hurt since when is
it about anybody else other than us? No,
but people did tune in. If
they like it, they like it,
but you don't do it for other
people like, yeah, hold on, joke.
Don't send to an artist
talk and shot at first
watching, watching, doing yoga.
I use Instagram challenges is you're
holding your breath challenge like goes,
he really holding his breath. I
don't fucking know. Well Burt,
everyone doesn't have to be in on every
goddamn thing you do everyday until you
get a shirt. Hey guys, going to bring
you in here. Ooh, Shit. Champion. This
the,
she
used be shit on Instagram first ever.
Probably.
What did the girl say when you're,
you're boasting when I pose it like dad's
mom [inaudible] funny that you don't
use the n word.
Oh my God.
He's got a girlfriend and just trying to
stream and provide for the family. Yeah.
Fuck them.
They don't realize I've leveraged their
futures for our income right now. Yes,
that's what it is. Yeah. You
paid a hefty price. Oh Dude.
Yeah. My kids do not like that. I've
talked that much about them. Well,
you should probably not have done that.
I'm trying to,
he's like 20 fucking 20 Joe early on. He
was like, really? You mentioned your kids.
You're like, yeah, what's
the, what's whatnot? I was
told to wait a long time ago.
My kids are fucking stupid.
He said, that's what he said.
He said, they're not
even gonna know. I go,
what if people come out to in
the mall and they said, Hey,
your dad was talking
about them like idiots.
Oh my God. I called George on
the phone on stage the other day.
Everyone was yelling island.
They're like, no, I'm Georgia.
The smart ones. Oh, don't,
don't look.
Hey [inaudible] 20 I was being honest.
I didn't know another way to do
stand up. I get it. I get it. Yeah,
you do it one way is just fine for
most of the world. That's the thing.
Like most things are fine
for most of the world.
It's just a small percentage of people
that are just wired all fucked up.
I guess we gotta. We gotta go. I gotta
go soon. It's up to 10 to six. Yeah.
We gotta go. No, I think you're going to
see the law online. Can we see anything?
Well, I'll stand to you and I'm not
going to look. They walk your number.
I'm telling you. [inaudible] look at it.
No music. Just show her videos. If we're
going to do it, we should break dance.
Go to stance elements. Stan.
Tell events and what's,
watch some of these guys do it. Here's
a video shot. Faker. Chet faker.
Oh fuck. This is great. Yeah. Some dance.
Look, I'm a real dance glazer. It's,
I'm telling you this. How will
shoot it. I'm a fan of this girl.
Dee Glazer's her name. She's
a choreographer. She got
blonde hair. Give her Nelly,
Nelly, uh, uh, from the loop and I'm
proud of you can't, we can't play it.
Play the music. Just watch her
dance. Okay, let's watch it.
[inaudible] we'll be doing Joe.
And I really think you're gonna like,
what are you selling this? I'll get this.
I'll get this job. I'm already out. No,
Joe. Yeah, right here. Fuck the
glazer. She's like cardinals fan.
Yeah. Country Grammar
first. This is us. Joe,
anything that doesn't
require you to lose weight.
I'm not looking for bodies in fucking
great show. This is us doing these.
Her name? Her name's Dee Glaser. Okay.
She's great. She's great. She's great.
And this will be us. Imagine how much
fun it would be when you do it though.
Cause you're fat. Yeah, I'll be,
do you think you could learn to do this?
100% you do things.
You can do a fucking split.
You remember that thing?
You could try it. You get a hold
on. You think you could do this.
I could get my body to move that way.
If someone taught me and I spent the
amount of time on a month to month one
month, no, not as good as her.
I think in one month you could
be better than all of us. Oh,
I would definitely be better than you.
And that's all that counts, right?
Oh Jo Jo Jo. Come on. This is
me and Tom and you and Ari.
We do a s one altogether.
I'm like,
he likes the belt brow exit from a,
what's it called? In the back. All right.
Do you think you could learn to do
lists? Look over here, Bert. No. Huh?
No,
not getting rid of this.
So tell me a challenge that you think
is fair for that fits everybody.
Everybody should weigh in right now.
What do you think it should?
You don't have the parents in this
cause that place, that place like that.
It's right near my apartment.
I walk by on the way home from not working
out and I looked through the window
at them doing crazy dances like that.
I understand the
challenge would be I'm crazy and I'm
going to keep the grandma mobile moment.
I'm going to keep this. This is mine.
I liked this. I liked having it.
Look at that. Let's go for it at that. You
never can get this bird. I'm getting it.
If we do hip hop, you think so? You're not
with the weight loss challenge
you by man. By the way, if I may,
you should get a weight loss challenge
belt and I think we should probably make
one. That'd be a great idea.
Horrible fucking idea. It's
a great idea. Um, get on it,
Jamie. Order it up. We need
a weight loss challenge
with branded tour bus champ too.
I want a marathon bell. Okay.
He's the only one I've tried that
they give you like a button or something
when you, when a man or you run it.
They do you know why? Cause your
promoter had one. I saw him when I was
one of them erasers that go on top
of a pencil that nobody ever uses.
Triangles through writing.
Pens are so crazy and you use up that
erase or boy you need an external check
cam hands on the phone call
campaigns right now. He'll be,
he'll tell you how it's spirit now
listen, what about, what about, uh,
if we let this hold on and I had the
fucking greatest idea, the greatest idea,
whole bracket. When you remember if, if
we do with the hip hop challenge we need,
no one's going to be there to cheer
anybody in Queer that the judges,
it has to be just us if
you want. Yeah, you care.
Can't quit the judges. Are you
allowed to say that anymore? Yeah,
I think that's probably language.
I don't know. It's in the,
my friend Miriam Nakamoto snacks snack,
a Modo snacks.
So just us and then you get actual
judges don't know us to decide. Yeah,
you have to really make a place.
Three people learned it with Joe.
I think you just gotta say
alternative alternative.
Let's come up with something
where we don't need judges.
I don't want to bring judges in cause
then we have other people like then it's
going to get gross weight. Maybe it's a
bad idea to bring in judges one judge,
because it just happens the power over
to other people in our organization too.
I don't want to even talk to other people.
That makes sense.
I'm trying to cut people out of my life.
I'm not trying to add
to hip hop dance judges.
I don't have the time. The only
debt, the idea. I like Ari's idea.
No social media for a year. Except I
have an ambulator run. You could run it.
Just go Jamie, post it. We have no
video post it. I don't trust him. No,
you'd have to. You'd have to give
it up. I'm going to be in charge.
I got him over there. He's sneaky.
He's sneaky. He checked my dms.
Why don't we eat it for Tony [inaudible].
Who's the best? I'll see you at the STL.
Them Dick Pics. Common my way. Yeah, the
judges is a real thing. You're right.
Judges is a real thing,
but I think we're in the right
direction with hip hop dance. Why?
Cause it's your invention. No, no,
no. I just think it's something silly.
[inaudible] you lose again.
There should be a real penalty for how
it be a real repercussion
for you in the first place.
I don't like Jolan top dance and we'll
put in the word. This is a good one.
If you come in last, you give
us, spread it out collectively.
$1 million.
Well,
you're doing better now.
It's 12 bucks, champ. You've
got that blog tour, bus champ.
You have to think about that.
Just sign up for,
you're not going to lose if those are
the stakes. What is the common division?
Wait, hold on. Hold on one second.
Let's let aside, let's talk tour.
Bus Champ comes at a price.
Dude, my bus was so fucking sick.
You can't just be tour bus champ. His
or his fight. I was taught about chip.
Listen, listen, but Bert, do you
understand that this is strange,
that you keep failing at these things
and yet you keep bragging every time we
get together,
contemplate,
have so much success when it comes to
you guys that I think sometimes you guys
forget about it. I was trying
to share, hold on a minute.
I was talking about sham admitted.
Admitted me.
[inaudible] Nelson Alive, don't
you? What do you don't talk to?
You're not the tour bus champ.
The bus that I was on this week is
better than anybody else on the tour bus
championship was going on already
asking me who's tour bus trip.
Let's say why it's me. Of course I'll
come cause I have the better bus.
Did you ever take a picture of your bus
and put it online? Yeah. Oh really? Yeah.
You and you had fucking
Photoshop to a hundred times. No.
The outside of your bus doesn't count.
Tom,
the inside of your bus that
looked like a prison yard.
It just looked like a prison yard too.
Did Not,
did it not have a broken transmission?
No Internet TV's that didn't work.
You had no internet on your toy box,
and I want you to pause for a second
and imagine a world where the thing that
you're bragging about when you have been
called out for failing to challenges in
a row heart,
first thing you talking about is this.
We're not even in the shape of the
bus that you drive around debt.
I didn't start talking about champ.
He started tour bus. Much is prepared.
What's was the transmission bad?
We'll then I win
a flat tire.
Well then I had a jazz show.
I'm Leonardo Dicaprio at the
front of and titanic. We,
we had a challenge who came at
last told me somebody who was like,
what are the repercussions for
you fucking pussing out. Well,
I'm not putting out fucking founded.
The reasons why I have this right here
is because I read about you saying that
you're going to put it on your mantle
piece and I'm like, that's never done.
You're Mickey mantle piece. That's
[inaudible]. Joe, can you entertain?
Can you entertain a circumstance in
which you think Burt could beat you?
Hip Hop may make again like the
old hustler make an even game.
It could be anybody's at this point
look a pool games or no,
no, no. When I play pool,
but like I'm not going to finish up on
the challenge that where it's like you've
got to make it the way back to be.
I'd have to have some form of lymphoma
really wrong with me, a physical
thing, but he'd moved so well.
Maybe you move like the
wind is something I've seen.
You move that Christopher Cross on Terry.
Shiloh couldn't move better than you and
you really can meet with Matt de Berg.
There was days where I was,
I was like, man, I'm tired.
And then I thought about you
already standing there. You took your
socks off, you fucking mushrooms.
We took some mushrooms and you forget.
Or both. I gotta go, man, it feels
good. That's what are we doing?
What are we going to have? We don't
have a agreement. Yeah we should.
And also you do need some repercussions
for fucking blowing it back.
[inaudible] I forget. I'm the
only one that ran a marathon too,
but it doesn't seem like you
are willing to face reality.
Tell me what reality
is. I'll fix it. Well,
of reality is Ari Shaffir didn't
work out at all the other ways.
Did Marathon Ari Shaffir I
didn't work out at decade.
I agree with you.
He's smoked you like,
why are you stressing anything
in life? And not just like, okay,
I'm probably you talking shit to
Ari didn't work out for 10 years.
I'm the only one that came in
with this checkpoint point.
What did you sit down? Do you ever see
the video of him on my fucking Rowan,
Michelle, I saw, here's the
deal. We teamed up against you.
Listen to my second place guy.
Let him use my teamed to go.
Can we team up?
I literally,
he's convinced that he was gone.
Give me this.
My closest competitor I told you day
off. That's true. I did. I just don't,
I've
said, I've said Ad Nauseum. We're not,
I can't believe we're covering this.
I've just had it at nauseum. Uh, Culligan
on Joe's Tiger's tail is a big mistake.
Ari was a massively surprising and
Tom was a fair, fair competitor.
Now I will say I am just giving up ideas
of what to do next October and I need
ideas and I believe that Ariz idea was,
I think us not doing something
is not fun to follow.
If you are a fan of the podcast, us not
doing it like, hey guys, let's sleep.
Wouldn't be really fun.
It would be,
it would be how many hours of hip hop
dancing and we put in, there we go.
Now we're talking about something.
Why hip hop dancing? Not Klezmer.
Let name it.
You guys want to do river dance river dam.
Fuck no dance.
It sucked when it was invented
dancing.
It's just hitting me right now.
Fast forwarding to [inaudible]
say another idea I'm in.
I'm in, but like I liked what
we did was with the hot yoga,
the easiest thing to do is something that
you don't need a lot to like take with
you or do you know what I mean? Like
it's not bad. I like running a lot.
I do raclette I'm running,
but I don't want to be the one
sitting here promoting running.
I'm trying to think out of the box.
Running is a great idea.
Great about running is that if we did
do it for the whole total miles of the
month, it would get savage
problematic. Would you?
Do you work? Uh, what burden?
I will seriously lose like 40 pounds.
[inaudible] name. What's the guys?
You just had an insert and he has
you do a marathon a day, Joe. Well,
I think it's physically
possible to do a marathon a day.
I know you could well be way
easier for me than for you.
They're much easier. Once again, I'm too
drunk to even talk to them. By the way.
I bet you looked at me like you're
like, I'm going to do that. Listen,
are you going to do a marathon a day?
It's not.
It's not healthy for you to keep living
in this world that you've created,
which doesn't even make sense, but are you
talking about my drinking or my no, no,
no.
That's normal.
The drinking along with this
proclamation of awesomeness.
You know what? I'm saying it's like just,
it's not the drink. The drinking is fun.
It's fun. You're fun running.
[inaudible] on rolling. Michelle,
you need to be punished if you lose
[inaudible] you want some make sense?
We got way more.
There's a whole table full of whiskey
over there and then we got cast monkeys.
Tequila here too. Let's do
running then. If everyone,
if everyone agrees on Monday I'm
in, I'm running. Can I ask you that?
Someone's going to get ugly guys.
I'm just going to get ugly.
I'm going to do a marathon and where are
we going to wear to track are so that
everybody has the same
thing to track the shoe.
Well you could wear the rock shoe or you
can just get an apple watch. No, no, no.
But that way we could do or watch only
for phone calls and then talking to it if
you have a of text messages and then
I'll do Ari's challenge at the same time.
So it will be doing our need for
social media for the month. So wait,
hold on. Running on an iPhone. We'll do
as many miles as we can for the month.
And the whole thing would be how
many miles can you run in a month?
Am I tell you I'm going to open up
the first day with 30 30 30 miles.
I'm going to open that up. Yeah, hold
on. No. Are we talking 30 miles in a day?
That day I need to do 30 miles.
Can you, here's the thing,
cause it earlier today that that
part I believe, I do believe that.
I believe that. Here's what
I want to know. This makes
a huge difference. Can you,
cause if we're tracking those miles,
we all have to track the miles.
We have to track them out
with the same APP, 30 miles,
which we're off to track the mileage.
The with the same APP. No, again, don't,
we're in front of us but not so that
you have to agree. No growth hormone,
no test or on. So it's a great, great,
great [inaudible] but you should get off
high blood pressure medication before
you get on anything.
What you should kill yourself first
and then figure out the rest. Yeah.
Her shit she should see as large as you.
Hold on.
You got all the way down to like
two 12 or something like that.
What did you weigh?
The impulse problems first search.
What did you get up to on this tour?
Tell them 500 euro
tell you a secret.
[inaudible]
picture showed it and it was such a
fucking disgusting picture of Burt and
Burgos was a shellfish reaction.
Denmark. Shellfish reaction in Denmark.
That's hilarious. Okay,
wait, wait. Here's the way.
Now this is important for the challenge.
So we all,
I think we all have to track the
miles the same way. Right? Is,
is there going to be a stipulation that
these miles can only be tracked outdoors
on pavement? Yes, because
it's, you're on a treadmill.
If it's GPS treadmill's not gonna show
anything on GPS. It has to be movement.
Okay. Actually a surgical move.
Mead we're talking about, no,
it just distance run verse walk this.
There's an app I saw recently that tracks
walking and it takes a lot longer to
walk.
A mile done to run a mile.
But you walk all day because
you know you should be,
if you're tired and you're running and
you want to walk for a mile, that's fine.
You remember this little lady all
distance walking around silver lake.
Do you ever that guy?
No. Silver Lake Walker.
This dude looked like a fucking lizard.
He just walk around Silver Lake Dude.
He would walk. I'm not
kidding. He was all from, yeah,
from like 6:00 AM. And you would
see him at 8:00 PM schizophrenia.
He was a doctor? Yes. He, there
was like a little scandal there.
He died in this hot tub. So you would
see this guy in a hot tub somewhere.
There he is the guy that's him.
So he would just walk around
and trying to slink Dick.
I don't know what guys slings, debt.
And he would hold the newspaper.
I used to see this dude [inaudible]
around like that. Yes. All Day.
So he would read
it,
said click on that lower picture again.
It said he killed himself. Look at that.
Killed himself. Yeah.
Oh my God. That's wow.
This has conclude hailed
himself. La Corner concludes.
Yeah. Well see had there,
but that wasn't initially the,
the report about story, story,
story,
that it was a mystery how this guy had
died while there was a history song. Yeah,
I guess of about Rutgers.
Yeah.
Can I tell especially where like, well
who says, oh, the corner. Okay. Toenails,
driveway. What you did there? Can
I tell you to tone? It was late.
I was late to his stuff. Yeah, they're
pretty, he has his toenails painted.
They're all pretty,
he's got like really beautiful.
I'll take a picture with
Kathleen and Kathleen Madigan.
No Mcgee. Yeah, in Calgary.
Uh, can I just tell you this?
I was late for the stand.
This is like about a year ago when the
Stan was still open and I was like fuck.
And I started running,
how was it second?
I was at 16th Street and second avenue.
I started running and eventually
I was like, I was out of steam.
I had to like stop and I stopped. I was
at 16th Street, not yet to third avenue.
So I,
I tire out under a block show.
Really enjoying the idea of going into
this and just totally to run a position
last year. I don't know why you
got into like a fucking zone.
You got to know zone you. He thought
he was going to wait at one point.
The other runners body, he, there was a,
there was a moment somewhere around
week when you said, I got to go. No,
when you said I got to go hunting them
offline for a second. I was like, oh,
I'm close. Yeah. I had to go hunting
for but I shot an elk on the second day.
We have been a little more like you think
it would have been a little easier on
us if you had hiked hunted for five days.
Yeah, but that was wearing my thing,
so I was hiking. I was, I got
600 points one day hiking,
hiking, man, your heart
rate didn't use you fuck up.
You're going to came back from hunting.
You did more than that.
Can you just put yourself as a thousand
in a day on one day it's going to happen
yet.
One day,
100 I did 900 and then I came in here
and worked out for another hour after I
was done. So I did. That was hurting.
I was hurting that last day, man.
You guys shot. Remember?
Okay, October 18th you wait,
you're going to wake up and you go,
fuck. I have to just run a bunch now.
Christina's like, let's hang out.
[inaudible] I know, I know, I know. Yeah,
it's not going to be a mom puts a bad
month and you're all going to die.
I'm cool with it. There's that too.
You'll come in for a second for a second.
First of Cyrus probably first, but um,
maybe second something spectacular.
It seems outrageous that I'm
going to be getting on growth.
[inaudible]
we'd love to do growth.
I should go do that,
but let's sign off on this.
That you should definitely lose some
weight. Shouldn't just get on stuff.
You should stop drinking so much speaking.
It's going to be easy to
dude what Australia, you're
not going to drink at all
when you're over there.
You definitely won't drink.
I mean they don't even like drinking
and Australia and they'll set a good
example. Dog kind. They don't accept,
you're not tricking people go hard over.
Yeah.
Maybe you're not doing this fucking cut
up coke we're doing tonight for your or
for shirts right there.
You can have to do shoeys over there.
You're going to have to drink beer.
She would see me do the show either on TV.
I don't even want to know. Pull up
chewy. It's still good friend picture.
Yeah. Um, I like running. I
just, uh, I'm cool with it.
I'm cool with those social media. Your
ledgers walked into his own thing. Again.
I'm the only one that came
up with an idea that was fun.
It was like jumped on board with
it, man. I think it's a good idea.
I told you I like
durable. I do. I like it.
I like the hip hop it in terms of none
of us have any experience that's on par
with the Cam. Brent. You, that's great.
That's judging part is a true problem
in parts of real problem. It's,
it's an untenable issue.
You're going to bring in these people
and they're going to go the reason why I
thought Burt one the fuck outta here.
Yeah,
get the fuck Outta here. I see
from different story points, work,
even mixture points for that.
Fuck you Bert.
Fuck you. You can't win like
that. If you're going to win,
it's going to be you have to win
and that's what you're scared of.
You're scared of. We usually straight
up when something or wins for sure.
Sure.
Definitely 100% I love that you had or
to redline into my brain where you hit.
You can tell. You can see what gets
my heart rate. See anxiety forming.
I could see a forming in the
air above you is the order.
If we do the running thing, go
ahead and you get first. Okay,
you're promoter gets a second.
Let's just get third.
What's the promoter's name again?
Fuck. What's his name? The one guy.
The only use only.
I came in here today thinking I was going
to tell you guys like I'm out. Really?
You're doing it. You're doing all
right. We did mushrooms. You can't go.
You are doing this to doing
mushrooms for the show.
Might have been the fucking best
way to start this show. Feels good.
I'm gonna have to do that in November
I bought, my whole body is tingling.
It's like a nice match from high.
It's like it's,
it makes you realize what you
really like about mushrooms.
I've got November 3rd off. Are we, are we
gonna do a Gig together? The four of us?
Yes. I, Shit, I won't be here.
Where are you going to be? What?
The five flied back in November,
November 4th in New York all week.
You know what we should do in your work?
Let's go to New York all week.
We could two people down.
Okay.
Are you still doing winters out here?
Are you still doing the window?
I could do it in New York jobs. I
could do it in your show. Your show.
I know a venue or should know about
[inaudible] suggest that Jesus Christ.
So are you not coming out this way
at all? Uh, no. I, I, I come at it,
you know,
it'd be fun if we decide like the four
of just decided to do a destination.
Like I'm drunk some crazy thing in Vegas,
but that's not like really a destination
like Saskatoon, you know, we should do,
we should do some shit that's like,
that you don't normally get on a
tour like somewhere in Wyoming,
you know what I mean? Or Ida. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I do Boise, Boise. I love boys.
Um, maybe we could do something
in like, um, slick guy,
Boise break his Ankle Co. Yeah, Mexico
or New Mexico, Not Mexico. Mexico, Bro.
New Mexico. I had ed called
her on the podcast of the day.
That's where I got this. Oh yeah, he's
Super Mexican. He's a border patrol guys.
He was describing the whole cartel wars
and how it all went down while it all
was happening.
Right when he signed up to be a cop and
he basically became a para operator,
like Jesus just trying to fucking deal
with shit that was going down the border
to try to take that and
then how to space it out.
So it's crumpled up trying
to get greedy hands, Montana.
What it is my [inaudible] Montana just
for us to hang out for the weekend show
to do it.
We'll do show and hang out or we
say November or November of Montana.
No. Yeah, as far as I go there
in November. Whew. All right.
Unless you like skiing. Well that's
when people go there for, yeah,
November's a season ready. She'll,
yeah, for sure. My Tommy in New York,
two days in big sky.
Saturday you're going to be there anyway.
Saturday. It's snowing in big sky.
He's going to be there that weekend
anyway, in November, New York. Yeah.
I'm going to be New
York and I got November.
Third off is my only weekend off
from standup all fall. Great.
Right after that weekend you come back
while hanging out Nila we and by the way,
we could just do a comedy
club to who gives a fuck?
Yes. That might be really fun,
man. Just book get charged so much. We can
charge their normal amount. The Bertram,
it's usually [inaudible] shake your hand.
Yeah. Have your promoter. I've never
charged. He didn't shake my hand.
You don't do that anymore.
I've never charged for meet and
greet in my entire life. That's fair.
Who says I'll never once I do.
I do a raffle.
People that do to take goes.
I think it's gross too,
but I bet you know what teaches
own friends to do it. I get it.
I told everyone agreeing on running.
Is that really going to be as easy
as crass what we did last time.
We've got plenty of time.
You have to agree to something Doug,
just because it was like, oh, fucking
time is running out of the podcast. Okay.
Hip Hop dancing and obviously
my first shirt fighting.
It's weird like that.
Let's split this roommate believe this
right in here for every show I do from
though like it look so pretty
bird. Huh? What'd you do?
Running the bed.
He wants it back and bad.
Who made that? Joe? What is the company
that made it pro and belts pro. Amp Bell.
Can you add an add on that shows a bunch
of pills on the side? Yeah, no weed,
no booze. It's like that's all there is
to try to keep it clean. It looks nice.
I can't wait for him. The belt.
You're going to have it, bro.
You have November 1st for
sure. Listen, I'm, I'm,
I'm well aware of what the training that
needs to go into this if we do running.
No, I personally think something
silly or would be benefited us,
but I'm cool with whatever you guys
pick because you're happy coming in last
with no consequences. Are you? Are
you saying you'll win either way?
No matter what it is. He just comes in
last. It doesn't matter. That's the thing.
Collapse all this shit. He riles you up
and I'm saying this is a guy who won.
It's not, it's not. It's not
right. Is it? W wait, do, wait.
How about the million dollar pair?
Are you going to do the million dollar
[inaudible] promote? It's not right.
Not Right. You fake
bragging's no shit. Bullshit.
I believe in my own fucking abilities.
That's the, that's horrific.
I believe a moment of those
horrific thing you said,
I believe in my own abilities. I
believe in myself. Yes. Las Vegas.
We'll open the action on this this year,
which we might be able to get them to do.
I'll say I know,
I'm betting I how many
things be honest challenge.
Just one every day he's got
to dre and today three weeks.
Seven mile. Four, three, seven
on that fucking bullshit.
That fucking awesome, right?
God, it's so hard at the air runners,
assault runner. I used to hate it.
Now I'm like that's going to get you in
shape for the real running that you have
to do when you come in last. Oh Man. Cause
that is harder than actually wait, wait,
wait.
Those things are harder than running.
It's like 15% or 13% I think he'll
do come in second again. I think so.
Yeah. I'll come and
second. He'll get crazy.
You're doing the thing that
you're kind of doing the opposite.
You guys are already better
than you guys know. All right.
Cause Ari and I have done Jujitsu together
so I know how competitive he gets.
Like when you're,
when you fight and for your life,
which is what you're doing
when you do what you did.
So you know what a guy's got
inside of them are extreme fears.
A little savage [inaudible]
life and running is a little
different. No, no, no, no,
no, no. It's his mind. That's why I knew
why I knew was going to come second.
I knew he was going to come in second
when we did this sober October thing.
I was just, yeah, it's two
fold. I'm running. I'm cool.
He gets crazy with stuff.
Let's go. I'm gonna Change my brain. I'll
switch it over. Let's go. Thank you Bert.
He doesn't, yeah, he doesn't
give up. Oh, oh, oh yes.
Now you to feel it. God doesn't
fold. This is already set up. What?
I feel like the only thing that's
not settled is led to, right.
That's not good for you. What's a good,
it's not good to talk shit and then talk,
listen, Talk Shit. And
then just to say, wait,
what is the big numbers comment?
I am Conor Mcgregor.
Nope.
Sometimes you talk shit and
you lose three years by Connor.
Sometimes you talk shit and you
lose. Okay. What's the punishment?
You just said I'm Conor Mcgregor.
Like kind of guy get knocked out.
Josie Aldo with one.
Conor McGregor was going to pick one
person on this podcast to get behind.
Who Do you think it would
be be? Breo it seems weird.
He compensated and be like my guy.
I'll bet [inaudible] he
would do one on the window.
Can I tell me what he would
do? Let's team up. Let's help.
This is what Connor would, they got them
on mushrooms. If there was a fucking,
if there was an audience,
he would get them all going about how
it's you and then when it's like press the
button to vote. Right.
Then he would go, Ciao.
[inaudible] Rogan.
Talk about your showmanship and you'd like
to, do you think you would lose money?
Just cause he likes that you get drunk?
That's a good point. It's a good question.
He loses money cause he loves that you
brag and then fall down and then get back,
get back, get back, get back out of a man
who doesn't think with his liver. Yeah.
I think with my heart hurt.
What is the punishment [inaudible]
group on it. But I'm saying, let's say
let's start with you. You come in last.
What is the punishment for coming in?
Last name it $1 million.
So happy right now.
I can't even wrap my head
around the last. No, he's happy.
He's looking forward to it.
Comfortable.
He's looking forward to coming and lasted
in front of a fireplace, curled up.
Ah, no, no names.
Look at him, dude. This whatever's wrong
with me, but if it got me into comedy,
all the things that are wrong with me,
this is the base of it right here.
I set up my therapist on there. What
does that mean? Because content,
I believe I genuinely,
oh, are you believe in me. Believe in
myself in this moment. That's great.
I genuinely believe in myself. I
believe that you do that. I do.
I believe that you believe in yourself
a hundred percent to a hundred percent
thank you.
Also,
I know on some level you'll come in
fourth in anything we don't know about him
or set forth, but I'll tell you, I'll
be, I'll be very honest. Yeah, please.
As much as I believe in myself.
I know there's something wrong with Joe.
I know that Ari has this fucking have
no interest in you Gehrig's disease.
That's already this year.
Whatever it is,
Mickey Mantle and I know that Tom is
going to call me on the last day and go,
who you're done running,
right?
You're not going to throw me
under the bus on this one.
[inaudible]
how did you do that on
the last day I called him
but I fought him on track.
Now I'll try calling them on a treadmill,
Jim and I was like, I was moving. I was
like, are you doing? He was like, man,
I swear to you, and then I,
he's like doing, he goes,
I'm with my family right now.
I'm with my kids and I heard like kids
laughing and pds like roasting a thing.
I stayed on that trip.
I was like,
I still on some part of my
mind doesn't believe you.
I didn't believe I stayed on. I stayed
on and he goes, I swear to you, I'm done.
And I stayed in that
gym probably 40 minutes.
He's still put up good numbers that day,
but I did go like I couldn't do it.
It was a weird thing. I didn't
tell you guys. I got up.
I flew across the country then. Yeah, no,
you did tell me. Did I tell you that? Yes.
So I was like,
Oh shit about it.
What I loved about it is that we were
seeing everybody's numbers and he's high
on mushrooms, but I'm just
thinking about this. It's like,
can't we start slow and have like a art?
You did five miles call for the day.
It's me out. No, that's not it.
That's not how it's going to work.
Going to the dark place. Here's
what I'm well aware of. Oh,
I'm going to give you the
cards in my hand right now.
I've run a 26 miles in a day.
Yeah,
and I know that Joe's first day of running
26 miles is going to put him back for
a couple of you said really
hard to go right into that.
So now he's going to train ahead
of time in October 1st you moron.
No, I know. I know. I know. I know.
I know when I know for a fact,
I know for me to leave this
place, its start. If we make,
if that's the agreement
I'm to get down to a 180
pounds. I'm going to lose
2100 I can do that. Nobody.
I mean like like in your head. Oh I'm
sorry. 20 pounds. It's already done.
Yeah. I'm going to lose 20
pounds and I'm going to run.
I will start off like with 10 I'll do
like 10 every other day and then by the
time October ramps around, I'll be doing
a marathon a day. It's kind of suck.
It's going to suck. You'll do that
every day. Yeah. I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to show
her what the fuck is up then.
I'm not gonna talk to him anymore.
I don't like how the end of the
it lasts. I'm going to block his number.
I'm just like, I can't do this anymore.
Fuck hip hop dance is so much more fun.
All right. This shouldn't be fun. I got
to pee can be fun. It shouldn't be fun.
She'd be terrifying.
Last year was terrified.
If I come in last this year and there's
all these fucking repercussions,
and then he came in last and had
nothing wrong with that. Right.
It's super unfair. It's unfair.
Right? Someone should punish you.
You should be punished. Birth.
Wait, why do I get punished?
So give me a punishment.
Punishment APP.
Eat your own shit. How much I spoonful
Jesus Christ. Oh Shit. What happens?
I don't know. Why don't you just give
us each 300 grand and it's settled?
Ah, fuck. Ugh. Can I just say that?
I'm going to be Columbus next weekend
so you guys will come out and see where
the fuck I love that place.
Even bigger, right? Yeah,
but don't do strokes when you come to
see my show. Just don't do it. Great.
Club Columbus. Yeah, that's great club.
It's a great town for stand up to.
It's not as good as the met. July
27th in Philly. Oh my God. Oh,
I'm announcing a shitload
of dates tomorrow. Are you
ready? Yeah, I know some. No,
I can't. I don't know where I'm going.
In Cardiff, Wales, June 25th for Ari.
Shapiro [inaudible],
shapiro.com all of them will be
announced tomorrow. I'll put it,
but um, I got some dates coming. Let's
do your presale. So there's some,
there's still a hundred tickets
left for Chicago this weekend too.
Where are you at in Chicago?
Some arena.
Jesus to Rogan eyewear at Chicago
in Salads. And they were like,
this is fucking super sweet.
The Salad. And then we asked,
some lady were like, couldn't
believe it. And we're like,
did you put sugar on the salad? And
she was like, is it too sweet for you?
Why would you put down your chicken
and salad? And we looked around,
the fittest person looked like Burt. It
was like everybody there was massive day.
Love that fat deep dish pizza.
Those are hardy. Midwest folk. Yeah.
I love San Diego. Yeah, I love Chicago.
Yeah, but they put sugar on their salad.
One moment. Take a break. Nope. Get into
it for just one extra pop with your pop.
Yeah. Want more sugar on your shout
sugar? Where are you playing there?
A massive place, Huh? Yeah. Some big ass
place. Damn. Is it different than this?
Like, how different is it than the
store? This is different. Yeah.
Explain to people the difference between
a small hundred seat room to it's five,
six. But here's the problem is the same
material you're gonna put on a special
deliver.
When you deliberate a 6,000 people
realize you're delivering to one person on
the couch. Is it like, do you,
it's different kind of show.
Do you find yourself talking louder or
like stuff like that? It's different.
I mean if you're there,
it's fun,
but I don't think it would translate
correctly if you're at home.
And that's one of the reasons why I think
like I did my last one at the Wilbur,
which is pretty tight. He's like three
comedy clubs stacked on top of each other.
It's 1100 seats, but it's pretty intimate.
Like the people are on top of you.
I think that's how you're supposed to
do comedy at a special because specials,
it's hard to be in that room.
And I, I've been saying this,
I don't see if you agree with me. Um, I
think that a special is only at its best,
like maybe 80% of what it's
like to actually be in the
room because you miss the
feeling of being in the crowd and I
tried to get my shirts and I haven't ever
gotten as close as possible
to love experience,
but you can see a show at a Mexican
restaurant on a Tuesday with a bunch of
amateurs and you'll laugh.
You'll laugh harder than watching any of
our specials on loan in your apartment.
Yeah. Comedy has you really being there
live, it's amazing. What makes it,
that's what makes,
I think a lot of comics mess up and they
do their special for the room and they
go like, oh, what's up? What's up
here? The place I'm at, I'm at Dell,
but Kat Williams,
the best part of his special was the 10
minutes he did on Tallahassee or checks
and jack die hard disagree
by the way,
shout big fucking Katt Williams fam that
I loved that he was John Williams stuff,
but we talked about that, about
doing it, not for the rooms.
You've got to do it for the people.
You shoot a special for fucking Jackson,
but his window, you guys especially
are doing these massive, massive,
massive rooms.
But then when people are going to see
your special almost hold them are watching
like,
you know,
really tough doing my special in a big
room up to it's like less than a thousand.
I'm thinking of doing a, at the icehouse
I've been thinking about doing that,
talking about for a while. I'm pretty
far out and doing special. I'm,
I'm at least a year away
from even thinking about it.
I think the most important thing about
other special is doing in a place that
has not seen you do stand up. That's
the number one most important thing.
I would do a special at the store.
Uh,
I would find that to be a mistake
because you're there all the time.
You've been working on this
material in front of those people.
If it fucks your head up. What
about the people who, well,
I got it on the level of like some of
the jokes are surprise ending and they
kind of like know what's going there and
they're like, right, right. That's true.
You don't want to do a special for
people that have seen this material ever.
You want those people to never have
seen this material the same way.
The people that are home never seen
that 1 million people in their labor.
You have a job.
A lot of them will show up.
A lot of your two mega fans are
going to show up and go, dude,
I just saw them like six months ago.
I want to come and see it. Well,
what's interesting about the store
right now and say you get comedy tourism
there,
where are you getting a lot of people
that come to visit the store from all over
the world? Yeah, true.
Let's see. I met some dudes,
they're just the other day
from England and Ireland.
They flew in for the weeks while
stand up stories in massive right now,
great stores everywhere, man.
Really is. But I, but I, I'm the,
the two things I have in my head is,
Oh,
like a rock venue and I'd
like a place I haven't done,
I haven't done this material in
front of you announced it yet.
Where are you doing or no? Yeah.
Cleveland 23rd of November.
Everybody special. Yeah. Oh, Shit.
And Cleveland and keep it short
sided shirt on. No, no, no.
I'm going do shirt on the super skinny
after this marathon doing it shuts off.
Come on Bro.
I'm not fucking knee brace on orthopedics
challenge sunburn on a walker.
You're like Forrest Gump.
Hi everybody.
I'm in there running.
When Ariz around you open up a Kombucha.
You instinctively smell it first.
Move that thing man.
I got thirsty too.
I would,
I could do an entire podcast on specials
cause I feel like I'm obsessed with how
they, the good ones. Like what makes a
great special? Yeah. Anthony. Jessalyn.
Nick's first. Jayson, the
best joke I've heard in a,
like this first jokes that come out really
strong. Got To have a first joke, man.
Anyone,
anyone who says hi,
any of that bullshit fucking walked in
states like Jeff or nick or like Norm
Mcdonald and tell fucking
Jovi's see it now. No Man,
I'd like Katt Williams got Jack Town.
I liked that.
It wasn't their incident. He's really
great. He's really great. But he, um,
when you see being real
man, I'm a calming. I'm not
a fucking, I'm being real.
I did this [inaudible] pussy foot,
the guy,
but like,
I didn't like it man.
I'm not from Jacksonville and I'd been
to Jackson and I, and I know Jay. I know.
Come on, come on, go to it
was fucking brilliant man.
You know what Michael Jackson had? He had
this, this, this, you know what I got?
I got this. I'm trying to fuck
bitches, man. It doesn't matter why.
It doesn't matter where he
is today. I doesn't, I want
to hear your new goals bow,
but he, no dude. Uh, and this podcast,
no conclusion because otherwise we'll
be just fight with Jon o'clock in the
morning. Cat night did Steve
Drunk Cat Stevens is a Muslim.
Don't get in a fight with him. It's a lot
of people. That guy's back. What's your,
I'll be your special strong.
I am being followed by a
moon shadow moon shadows.
Okay. All right. This is a wrap.
Ladies and gentlemen, Sober October.
We accomplished nothing.
Can I promote one thing real quick?
If you ever wanted an
excuse to do mushrooms,
there's a mushroom festival happening in
just two weeks. June 15th, 16th and 17th.
All got to do is take my
shoulders wherever you are.
It's called shoot fast and fucking join
in by taking mushrooms. Uh, listen. Uh,
this was fun, man. It
was good time to talk.
I love you guys. Okay? Yeah. Talk to me
a can't fucking, I'll late October. Yeah.
Well you'll get it ugly again.
Thompson,
grow.com fucking asshole.
[inaudible].